yeah the White House meeting in the Oval
Office that he desperately sought this
for that president Trump has repeatedly
insisted that his July 25th conversation
with President Solinsky was a perfect
call his staff at the White House
apparently believed otherwise the press
office issued a short and incomplete
summary of the July 25th call let me
read it for your hearing today President
Donald J Trump spoke by telephone with
President Vladamir zolensky of Ukraine
to congratulate him on his recent
Juden arms will restore order in the
gallery
and the scripture says for the Lord
loves justice and will not abandon his
faithful ones official White House call
readout July 25th 2019 today President
Donald J Trump spoke by telephone with
President Vladamir zolensky of Ukraine
to congratulate him on his recent
election President Trump and president
Solinsky discussed ways to strengthen
the relationship between the United
States and Ukraine including energy and
economic cooperation both leaders also
expressed that they look forward to the
opportunity to meet that is the official
White House call readout dated July 25th
2019 the official readout provided to
the American people
o many key elements of the president's
conversation let's review the official
readout did not mention the phony
investigations requested by President
Trump the official readout did not
mention the oval office meeting sought
by president zalenski the official
readout welcome back men yeah we had to
do switchover but we are now only on
YouTube there was some kind of an issue
with our twitch stream this is part two
of day three we're just doing it on
YouTube for now YouTube super chats will
show up over there we're still carrying
over everything that happened previously
including welcoming max dawn who is new
member number 89 hopefully this part 2
of the stream will get us to the 100 new
members will go back to Hakeem Jeffries
and we are expecting a break close to
the bottom of the hour we are back just
on YouTube now the complete conversation
however between presidents from
and president Solinsky that we just
outlined offers powerful evidence that
President Trump abused his power and
solicited foreign interference in a 2016
election the 2020 election several
members of the president's staff
listening in on the call immediately
grew concerned as he sat in the White
House Situation Room listening to the
conversation
Lieutenant Colonel Alexander VIN men
realized that the president's demands of
the Ukrainian leader were inappropriate
and improper he quickly recognized that
as the president began referencing the
Biden's and CrowdStrike
the call was diverging from the official
National Security Council approved
talking points that he helped prepare
Lieutenant Colonel VIN men 20 year Iraq
war veteran Purple Heart recipient and
American patriot he testified in the
context of the call that due to the
unequal bargaining position of the two
leaders and Ukraine's dependence on the
United States the favor that President
Trump sought would have been perceived
by President Zelaya we did have a
protester let's see if we can quickly
check out what happened I think I have
video of it president Donald J Trump
spoke by telephone with President
Vladamir zolensky of Ukraine to
congratulate him on his recent
[Music]
[Applause]
Jenning arms will restore order in the
gallery all right and that probably is
all that they will really give us of it
they don't rhyme sure want to promote or
encourage this sort of thing let's get
back to the audio here if Ukraine
pursued an investigation it was it was
also clear that if Ukraine pursued an
investigation into the 2016 elections
the Biden's and Bruce Moe it would be
interpreted as a partisan play this
would undoubtedly result in Ukraine
losing bipartisan support undermining US
national security and inventing Russia's
strategic objectives in the reason we're
counting the content of the call based
on his detailed handwritten notes
Lieutenant Colonel Ben Minh told the
lawyers that he believed it was wrong
for president Trump to ask president
szalinski to investigate Vice President
Biden other witnesses were also troubled
by what they heard vice president
Pence's advisor Jennifer Williams
expressed concern their president Trump
raised a domestic political matter on an
official call with a foreign leader she
testified that the mention of
Investigations struck her as unusual and
possibly political in nature she said I
guess for me it shed some light on
possible other motives behind a security
assistance hold Timothy Morrison a
former Republican congressional staffer
who replaced dr. Fiona Hill in July of
2019 also reported the call to national
security council lawyers after the call
President Trump continued to push the
scheme forward on July 26 the very next
day ambassador Sunderland and ambassador
Taylor met with President szalinski and
other Ukrainian
Jules and Keith according to david
holmes the ukraine base US diplomat who
served as the note-taker the Ukrainian
leader mentioned that President Trump
had brought up some very sensitive
issues during the July 25th call very
sensitive issues ambassador Solomon then
had a private meeting with Andre year
mark president zelinsky's top aide the
two men insisted that the meeting be
one-on-one with no note-taker perhaps
due to the sensitive issues that might
come up
ambassador Solomon testified that he and
president zelinsky's aide probably
discussed the issue of investigations
after these key moments in Ukraine
ambassador Solomon went to lunch with
David Holmes and two other American
officials mr. Holmes sat directly across
from ambassador siling close enough to
hear the details of an extraordinary
telephone call between mr. Sandlin and
president Truong as mr. Holmes relayed
during his sworn testimony under oath
ambassador somnolent pulled down his
unsecured cell phone and said that he
was going to call president Trump to
give him an update what happened next
was shocking
well ambassador silence phone was not on
speakerphone I could hear the
president's voice through the earpiece
of the phone
the president's voice was loud and
recognizable an ambassador Soglin held
the phone away from his ear for a period
of time presumably because of the loud
volume I heard a bass or song and greet
the president and explained he was
calling from keeve I heard president
Trump then clarified that ambassador
Stalin was in Ukraine pastor Stalin
replied yes he was in Ukraine and went
on to state the president szalinski
quote loves her ass
then her President Trump asked so he's
gonna do the investigation
ambassador song 'ln replied that he's
gonna do it adding that president
Solinsky will do anything you ask him to
do he's going to do it he will do
anything you ask him to do immediately
after this call with President Trump mr.
Holmes followed up with ambassador Samba
after the call ended ambassador Soglin
remarks that the president was in a bad
mood as ambassador Soglin stated it was
often the case early in the morning I
then took the opportunity to ask
ambassador Soglin for his candid
impression of the president's views on
Ukraine in particular I asked ambassador
Soglin if it was true that the President
did not give a expletive about Ukraine
ambassador song I agreed that the
President did not give an expletive
about Ukraine I asked why not ambassador
Sandlin stated to the president only
cares about big stuff I noted there was
big stuff going on in Ukraine like a war
with Russia an ambassador silent replied
that he meant big stuff that benefits
the president like the Biden
investigation that mr. Giuliani was
pushing the conversation then moved on
to other topics during the July 25th
call president Trump asked for the favor
of these two phony political
investigations
immediately after the Ukrainian
president brought up defense assistance
for Ukraine and the following day
ambassador sahlan confirmed
President Trump that Ukraine would
indeed initiate the investigations
discussed on the call which was the only
thing president cared about with respect
to Ukraine
he didn't care that Russia was
forcefully occupying eastern Ukraine
president Trump didn't care that
thousands of Ukrainians apparently have
died fighting for their democracy he
didn't see McCain at supporting Ukraine
bolsters America's national security but
he cared about himself as it relates to
the prospects of his re-election in 2020
in November president Trump denied that
he spoke to ambassador Sam Lin on July
26 telling reporters I know nothing
about that but in his public testimony
ambassador Solomon contradicted that
assertion with official records he
obtained from the White House ambassador
Sandlin further explained that Holmes
his testimony refreshed his reelection
about the July 26th call which
ambassador Solomon had not originally
described when he first appeared at a
deposition before the house also on July
26 shortly after our Kiev meetings I
spoke by phone with President Trump the
White House which has finally finally
shared certain call dates and times with
my attorneys confirms this the call
lasted five minutes I remember I was at
a restaurant in Kiev and I have no
reason to doubt that this conversation
included the subject of investigations
again given mr. Giuliani's demand that
president zalenski make a public
statement about investigations
I knew that investigations were
important to president Trump we are we
believe heading to a break they were
going to take a break at the bottom of
the hour which was four minutes ago we
anticipate that it'll be soon
then I will answer questions we may take
phone calls we'll do a whole bunch of
different stuff I don't know why milk is
the only drink other than water allowed
in the Senate chamber I'm not sure about
that I don't know if flavored milks
would be allowed or if they would be
considered a flouting the rules to some
degree may be a question we can explore
super chats will show up over there if
you send them embarassingly that entire
gray box on the screen is empty because
there's no super chats
it's an incredibly embarrassing
situation that hopefully people can help
remedy but we will get the super chats
maybe live calls and a whole bunch of
other stuff this is part two of day
three of the Trump impeachment trial
we're listening to Hakeem Jeffries to
target an American citizen for political
personal gain in a perfect call the
president would not solicit foreign
interference in the 2020 election in a
perfect call the president would not
threaten the well-being of a highly
respected American ambassador and say
that she was going to go through some
things in a perfect call the president
would not praise a disgraced former
prosecutor who the free world viewed as
corrupt and incompetent and in a perfect
call the president would not have
directed a foreign leader to follow up
with Rudolph Giuliani a human hand
grenade means this was not a perfect
call it is direct evidence that
President Donald John Trump corruptly
abused his power and solicited foreign
interference in the 2020 election
Wow Wow party leaders recognized mr.
chief justice colleagues will now take a
30-minute break for dinner and reconvene
at five minutes after 7:00 so I ask
consent the Senate stand in recess until
that time without objection so ordered
an incredible third day of Donald
Trump's impeachment trial we are now in
the house impeachment prosecution
managers have about 24 hours to present
their case against the president they be
yes okay so anyway we were in a
30-minute break and we can now get all
caught up on everything I will answer
questions coming in via super chat we
will we will hopefully get to our we've
never so the highest goal we've ever had
for new members on a stream before has
been 50 and we are just continually
rolling over our impeachment goal which
is now at 100
we're only 11 away we've never in the
history of streams had a hundred new
members up on the board so maybe we can
do it and in fact I say we just knock it
out before they even come back and
continue after their dinner what Mitch
McConnell will be eating known
colloquially as a turtle will he be
munching on Keros and lettuce or lettuce
or will he have a proper meal I couldn't
tell you
but we will we will soon find out I'm
sure Ren Holder 57 sends a super chat
and says thanks for the commentary David
my pleasure
Marika l who is still here Marika Li I
recall correctly Marika al is in
somewhere in Northern Europe where it is
probably between midnight and and 1:00
a.m. right now Marika says I'm too tired
to ask a thing but great work on the
streams thanks Marika always great
always great to see you here
and we will we will see what the last
portion of today brings I'm trying to
think how late they're going to go in
don't indulge me in a moment to run the
math if they're doing eight hours a day
of opening arguments and today is day
one they were scheduled to start at 1:00
I
think they actually started until about
115 or 138 hours would get us to 9:30
they already did like a 20 minute break
call it 30 that gets us to about 10 p.m.
they're doing a half hour break now
which would get us to about 10:30 p.m.
and there have been a couple of other
short interludes where I guess the timer
may not be running so I think it's not
unreasonable that this would run until
sometime between 11:30 p.m. and 1:00
a.m. maybe but I'm glad to hear our
thoughts from other people about how
late you expect this to go Ryan Henry
Dean says via super chat oh let's see
that's not on screen there we go Brian
Henry Dean says I think he will do a
combination of lettuce and carrots caval
x' ham says make sure you stay hydrated
David much lovey I'll take a quick sip
very important to sip water david
Tillery says david thoughts on how we
shorten this process I don't think
there's a listen if I don't know how
we're going to make it through this
because it is going to be excruciatingly
ly long it could be five weeks we're
talking about three days of Democratic
opening arguments three days of
Republican or opening arguments and then
they are supposedly going to be debating
witness subpoenas and document subpoenas
that could be another couple of days
that gets us to eight days senators will
have 16 hours to ask questions I'm
guessing that'll be two eight-hour days
which would be ten days that's ten
actual days of stuff but that doesn't
even include debate and discussion
rather testimony from witnesses and
presumably there will be some witnesses
you could be talking about ten or
fifteen days of that it could be three
weeks it could be five weeks we just
don't really know we don't really know
thank you - Todd carpenter for signing
up for a youtube subscription using the
join button down below
remember website memberships which are
up there are separate from hitting the
join button below we are targeting 100
website memberships and I want to say
thanks to nicole bender or binder nicole
bender or
finder who is new member number 90 we're
just ten away it looks as though Donald
Trump is doing something I guess leaving
Davos or maybe who knows what he's doing
let's see if they're saying I don't know
Dover New Hampshire taking a political
angle on what we're listening to
stripling Everett Washington republished
that Trump getting back to the White
House that is interesting if Trump is
back just while we have the time maybe
we will look at Donald Trump's Twitter
account and see if he's been tweeting
anything always good to get caught up
and then we will continue with the super
chats momentarily Donald Trump saying
thank you to the World Economic Forum
retweeting total bomb-thrower Doug
Collins retweeting Senator John Barrasso
retweeting more of Doug Collins
retweeting Marsha Blackburn a couple of
times Bill Cassidy
dr. bill Cassidy senator senator Ted
Cruz Sean Hannity
okay so all of the the sort of normal
stuff that you would expect saying if
anybody comes to the us-mexico border
they're going to be sent back if they're
part of that Caravan okay so nothing
nothing hugely surprising or shocking
they're mostly the the stuff that we
would expect to see from Donald Trump
once again there was a protester let's
see if we can just find that video
impeachment protest we'll take a quick
look at that your Trump spoke by
telephone with President Vladamir
zolensky of Ukraine to congratulate him
on his recent
[Music]
[Applause]
Jenin arms will restore ordinary word
that guy said does anybody in the chat
know what was actually said I'm just
gonna pay attention to the chat for a
moment here to see if anybody has any
idea what it was that was said there I I
heard I think I heard the word Trump in
that screed although over on the wrong
window although I am not completely sure
so somebody says they think Jesus Christ
was mentioned that's possible overturns
something yeah the word overturn might
have been in there Jesus Christ
something something Oh a lot of people
think it was a religious nut that's
interesting yeah let's play it one more
time and we have to we have time here
let's see President Donald J Trump spoke
by telephone with President Vladamir
zolensky of Ukraine to congratulate him
on his recent Jesus Christ something
overturned
I think is what I heard and some people
saying they heard the word noises in
there but I don't think I heard the word
noises in there oh he said iPhones 50%
off with the trading of a Mac Pro yeah
that actually makes a lot of sense I do
think that I that I heard that okay we
are in a break we're not missing
anything we are what about five and a
half five close to six hours into this
entire thing today for the next 20
minutes or so any questions or comments
or ideas about what we've seen today
please submit them via super chat that's
the dollar sign at the bottom of the
chat window if you were which I guess is
over there if you're on a desktop
computer it's an overlay on your mobile
phone if you're watching on mobile you
hit that dollar sign and then when you
type in a message however you do it type
it in or you know whatever
it'll pop up right over there as these
fine folks messages have including David
Tillery and cabal's Tam and ryan henry
dean and of course Marika from from
Northern Europe who is a staple of the
streams and we also have an impeachment
we are we celebrating in are we
celebrating impeachment I'm being told
we're not we're not celebrating
impeachment but we're commemorating
impeachment maybe better said with the
coupon code impeach 50 we have a goal of
100 new members on my website join
pakman.com the coupon code impeach 50
saves you 50% and I will just take a
moment to show you exactly how that
works you could do monthly or yearly I
say do yearly because you save more but
it's completely up to your preference
you hit the signup button when given the
option you type in the coupon code
impeach 50 and when you click off you
will see that $60 becomes only 30 for an
entire year and if you do a monthly
membership six dollars a month becomes
just three dollars a month for the
entire year ninety people have done it
so far and it would just be amazing if
we finished filling up this bar right
here we are
90/10 9/10 nine zero carry the zero zero
zeros 90 okay so we're 90 percent of the
way there actually that the math was
simpler than it appeared to me other
super chats coming in whren holder 57
let me see his rent holder on screen and
I'm actually concerned that we can't
actually see something we oh I see what
happened
nope that's not the right job there we
go okay there we go
rent holder 57 says something about roe
v wade perhaps I don't know exactly what
that means
James Buchi no says hey David were you
ever in - yeah he oh yeah he oh I don't
know what that is or Magic the Gathering
in high school or anything no I was not
into yugioh up former producer Lewis
made me play Magic the Gathering once or
twice it was not my thing
it was not my thing although I was able
to tap his mana and he never he never
forgave me for it young dumb and Baroque
welcome back that's a username I
recognize is there a chance of the
Democrats
asking roberts for a mistrial I doubt it
I doubt it it hasn't occurred to me
before but I highly doubt it let me say
thanks to Matthew Mayo Mayo of course
delicious topping for sandwiches and and
all sorts of foods
Matthew Mayo member 91 member 91 of 100
thank you so much I appreciate that you
Iike gas Gauss sends a super chat in
Swiss francs and says just another super
chat every time I see Swiss francs super
chats come in I'm reminded of the
delightful times that I've had in
Switzerland it's just such a great
country the food was terrific
the people were terrific pricey not a
place where you are likely going to get
away on the cheap for sure but a
beautiful beautiful country my time in
Switzerland mostly spent in Zurich and
Lugano
and Lugano is uh just an amazingly
picturesque place which I would
recommend to everyone I would recommend
everyone go to Lugano as soon as
possible truly the sooner you can get
there the better let's listen actually
what we could listen to c-span callers
for a moment but also the voicemail
number continues to explode let me see
if there's any new voicemails that I
want to play
yes very clean in Switzerland as well
people pointing that out are completely
correct uh let's see actually I don't
think we have too many new voicemails to
play that have been coming in while
we've been doing the stream let me check
the other spot let's see what other
voicemails we've got here
how about oh that racist Sam cedar
caller did leave a voicemail let's just
listen to it I'm glad it on Martin
Luther King Day he decided to talk yeah
Martin Lucifer Kuhn is not going to get
you
far on this show we'll just cut it not
not appreciating that Jesse Dotson is
new member 90 new member number 92
thanks Jesse really appreciate it 92
looking for 100 new members today a few
other super chats coming in M Gray says
can you explain a post facto
rationalization yes okay so we've
mentioned this term a few times over the
last couple of days interestingly enough
a post facto rationalization would be
post facto means after the fact so a
post facto rationalization would be an
explanation for something that you come
up with
after the relevant event has taken place
so for example a post facto
rationalization would be like if I let's
say that yesterday you know actually I'm
having trouble coming up with a good
example let me just see what examples
are online post facto rationalization
let's see what examples there are I'm
actually struggling to find a good one
post facto rationalization what is it I
don't want to use one that is even more
confusing does anyone in the chat have a
good example so let's see a good example
I have all the ones I'm coming up with
they're just going to confuse people
even more post facto rationalization
would be in the case of in the case of
Trump if Trump does something that
appears to be illegal or unethical and
after the fact you retroactively Lee
come up with a reason why he did it that
is seemingly benign you've evaluated
later in the most favorable terms
possible why you believe Donald Trump
did something but of course the fact
that you're doing it later makes it
invalid because you already have an
agenda that you're trying to carry
forward by couching what he did in the
least offensive or or damning terms
possible I still don't think this is
great let's see if there's any other
examples that are coming in via chat
people what people get hypnotized to do
something like opening an umbrella and
returning to their chain
err yeah these are not good examples in
any case IIIi think I've maybe confuse
people even more but let's let's go back
to it it's been a long day
Ryan Henry Dean says I hope people
aren't holding out to be member number
100 that would be horrible if people
were doing that let me say welcome to
Sarah officer Sarah officer and Jordan
deser neighs or deser nay who are new
members number 93 and 94 that gets us
look at how little that space is right
there it's almost like off-screen how
close we are to 100 new members that
join pakman.com we are at number 94
david Tillery sends a super chat and
says simply beer money thanks David Yuka
Gauss says also visit lucerne in
switzerland yeah I'd like to go I'd like
to go to Lucerne I've never been to
Geneva there are a lot of places
actually in Switzerland that I would
absolutely love to visit let's listen to
just a little bit of Senator Ted Cruz
one last observation yesterday
representative Nadler threw up great
indignation and he said out of hundreds
of thousands of Ukrainian companies how
could it be that President Trump was
just concerned with this one this one
company barista well the obvious answer
that the house managers ignore is burry
simha was the only Ukrainian company
that had the son of the vice president
that had real prima facie indications of
American corruption we're not talking
about some abstract interest in any sort
of corruption that might exist in
Ukraine but if you have a sitting vice
president making public policy decisions
to benefit his family to the tune of a
million bucks a year that raises a
serious question a corruption at a
president not only is justified in
asking for that to invest to be
investigated but has a responsibility to
see that that's investigated that was a
question not about Ukrainian corruption
but a question about American corruption
and Ukraine being integral in helping
investigate whether there was in fact
American corruption I think we're gonna
hear another date so when you're not
playing to the cameras
if you usually would look at the
reporter who asked a question but Cruz
is just playing to the cameras
the decision on calling witnesses is a
decision in the first instance for the
parties and for the party's Council's
and so the question I'm calling hunter
Biden is gonna be decision for president
Trump's lawyers to make initially if
they asked to call hunter Biden if they
asked to call hunter bite if they asked
to call the whistleblower if they asked
to call other potentially relevant
witnesses then the Senate will have to
make a decision whether to grant that
request I don't think the Senate should
force the parties to call witnesses that
they don't their lawyers don't make the
decision to call but I do think the
Senate has an obligation to conduct a
fair trial that means to respect due
process you know it was strike give me a
break there's that it is not a fair
trial the guys they suggested not
debating which witnesses to call until
after both sides have presented their
case what about that strikes you is it
even remotely fair trial let me say
thank you to Bill abilene bill Epling is
new member number 95 we are 95 percent
of the way to 100 new members using that
coupon code impeach 50 impeach 50 let's
just do it let's just get to that number
100
Timmy Lunsford says via super chat say
one nice thing about President Trump his
amber colored skin reminds me of a
beautiful sunset how about that
Robert agate see no guitar sends a $19
99 cent super chat with no question or
comment thanks Robert I appreciate I
appreciate the support very much we are
in a trake from the impeachment trial
scheduled to go from 6:35 to 7:05
question in the chat just a little
levity because this is going to be
dozens and dozens of hours who of the
Senators do you think is having the
weirdest dinner this is a dinner break I
know we joke about Mitch McConnell's a
turtle and he's having a dinner of
carrots and lettuce but who do you
really think is the senator likely to be
having the most bizarre dinner of all
during this 30-minute break and we are
expecting this to resume in about 10
minutes all of the breaks have been
longer than announced so realistically
it could be even longer if
just joining us please remember to hit
the like button only a hundred and
fifty-three likes on this stream that is
that's not great but um I I know we're
gonna start making our way to a couple
thousand so make sure to hit that like
button it does help this stream be
recommended by YouTube / / others Scott
white says via super chat
David assuming Trump is not reelected
what are your thoughts on Trump being
indicted once out of office particularly
at the state level in New York you know
if you make me bet on it I don't think
any of it happens I I believe that the
most likely scenario is the only
opportunity to hold Trump accountable is
to vote him out in November he is not
going to be convicted in this trial he
is not going to be indicted if he is
indicted he's not going to be convicted
criminally after he leaves office the
only opportunity to really have a
consequence for Trump we're talking
about him like he's a little kid is to
remove him in November if he gets
another four years he'll get the four
years he'll be outrageously extreme and
then he'll be out and that'll be it but
I would not count on anything else
Rainn H says it cracks me up whenever
you're Petty towards an unruly caller or
to Trump all right but glad I'm
entertaining you M gray asks how can
they eat in only thirty minutes are they
getting delivery I'm guessing staff has
something waiting for them something
that they must have something waiting
for them a lot of people think that Ted
Cruz probably is having the weirdest
dinner Amy Klobuchar is eating salad
with a comb that makes sense Bernie's
eating Soviet bread from 1959 okay
that's pretty funny Ted Cruz is eating
trump's behind fair fair Cruz is sucking
someone's blood for dinner some of these
I can't even say chicken nuggets I don't
even really understand that people are
eating Trump's taco bowl yeah that's a
good way to suck up to Trump have one of
his favorite from tower taco bowls
I guess flown in from New York City who
even knows okay Scott Phillips says this
is my third super chat I was going to
waste it to point out you didn't read my
last two but it's all good Scott I I've
been trying to read every super chat the
only ones I think I didn't get
- may have been lost in the transition
from a from a double stream here and on
Twitch over to YouTube and I apologize
for that but I was not aware of having
missed any I was not aware of having
missed any any super chats whatsoever
but I sincerely sincerely apologize
let's take a listen to a couple of these
phone calls coming in and see what's
going on you know but when you seeing
them introduce these things the way
they're handling themselves right now
it's very interesting and it makes one
thing you know what is going on is it
what's the right thing to do here right
hey you launder one one side question
you're down there in West Palm Beach
have you ever seen the president when he
visits Palm Beach when he comes down to
Marlo go well well actually I see the
airplane most of the time you know but
they always park it at Southern
Boulevard you know and but ya know I
haven't I haven't really had that
opportunity as a matter of fact now that
you're on you're on the air I also
wanted to say that when he first let me
tell you I was a Democrat and I were a
Republican I'd switch because of all the
stuff that was going on and Sekulow
going to say a word or two
we don't our position has been
consistent we they've got to meet a
burden to do that we don't think they
will this can be a decision that the
Senate makes but we're prepared for it
anyway it goes we're ready to go I mean
we've been ready to go for you know I've
been ready to go for 33 days so we're
certainly ready to go now we're glad
least the process are I'm not making
we're not making any determinations on
what witnesses we might call because we
don't know yet their case we're still
hearing it we'll see what happens we
don't even know if there will be
witnesses yes if he gets his way there
will be no witnesses which is absolutely
and completely insane zhu dane says via
super chat greetings from Cape Cod
curious if you've ever visited thanks
for the commentary and for keeping my
desk job interesting of course I've been
to Cape Cod probably five or six times I
have itlet's I'm gonna try to thank
everywhere I've stayed I visited Cape
Cod I'm gonna try to go from from inland
all the way out to Provincetown I've
visited West Yarmouth for a wedding
there's a great cafe near West Yarmouth
I think it's called snowy owl in snowy
owl in Brewster oh is that is are there
a couple of them snowy owl coffee in
Brewster I believe it is yes I have
visited Chatham or chase them as its
popular to say in some of our southern
states I've stayed in Wellfleet south
well flea I have stayed in I visited
Dennis there's a great place for
sandwiches called them the mercantile in
Dennis tell him I say hi if you go they
all no idea who I am I mean no one there
knows me but just tell him I say hi I
love their sandwiches and then of course
Provincetown Provincetown is a great
place and I've always been in the warm
months as is probably common for for
most people and I appreciate the super
chat thank you very much we are
potentially three to 20 minutes away
from the resumption we are on Donald
Trump's impeachment trial day three I'm
calling this part two and part one was
before our twitch stream got
disconnected part two is after where we
are now just on YouTube if you're just
joining us
welcome please before you do anything
else hit that like button
361 likes right now we're trying to get
to a thousand likes hit the subscribe
button we're trying to get to 800,000
subscribers by February 2nd which is my
birthday and we're only a few thousand
away I think we should be able to do it
and if you want to support the streams
send a super chat it'll show up over
there or sign up at join pakman.com we
have our most ambitious goal ever of 100
new members see it up there it's it's in
oh and in blue and white and we are five
members away from getting to 100 which
would be an historic accomplishment join
pakman.com is where you sign up epic
fails says via super chat I love these
former Democrats that Trump supposedly
turned I think is the implication yeah a
lot of them seem to call into c-span I
don't know if I believe it I mean you
know it's a it's a it's a politically
popular thing to say and politically
convenient to say you know I used to be
this but it's gotten so bad that now I'm
this other thing and I think some people
lie about that they think they're being
interesting some people are probably
telling the truth but it's actually a
concern if you the the Democratic and
the Republican parties over the last 10
years 12 14 years are so different
despite both perpetuating the status quo
on many issues that if you really
switched from being a Democrat to a
Republican than the last 10 years I
would wonder whether you're just really
gullible and you were tricked because I
don't see how anyone could really have
that sort of a political awakening and I
know that this refers there are cultural
critics and arbiters of ideas who have
had some of them are known to you
because they have YouTube channels who
have had such political awakenings I
find it weird I struggle to believe that
that's that's exactly as described
unless something is sort of wrong with
the person James montalbano
says via super chat do you think that
the Democratic elite would rather lose
to Trump than Bernie you know what's
very interesting about that I did a
story yesterday on the show
it's on yesterday's podcast but the
stand-alone youtube clip is not
publishing until i'm taking a look
might be until this weekend if you game
out the four scenarios meaning Biden is
the nominee and wins Biden is the
nominee and loses Bernie is the nominee
and wins Bernie as the nominee and loses
there is a game theory case to be made
to be made that progressives are best
off with Biden being the nominee and
losing in the long term I'm not going to
do this the whole analysis now because I
do it on the show yesterday and will
publish that but it's a very interesting
question I think this is Trump arriving
back from Davos fencing argument for you
okay there's a total lunatic on c-span
so we'll mute that right away I don't
want to subject the audience to that let
me say thanks to Blair Ilana Clark Blair
Ilana Clark is new member number 96 96
out of 100 at join pakman.com just four
to go four to go I say we just blow up
this one hundred new member target
before the Senate reconvenes here let's
see other questions coming in
oh we were going to do a couple of other
voicemails yeah let me get back to that
now that we have a little bit of a lull
but I will continue answering other
questions that come in here let's see
let's see what this one's about David
Beckmann
did you hear Donald Trump just always
just the son of a [ __ ] we need rhythm
in the football team he was insulted his
mother and father highly and did you see
the expression on the football players
faces they didn't like it yeah yeah let
me see this is actually fascinating
Trump hat let's see Trump football team
trumpet I just don't follow college
football so I don't even know I don't
even know what team it was but Donald
Trump had a
football team that ones something okay
this must be the LSU Tigers at the white
house and they seemed very unimpressed
with what Donald Trump said let's take a
look at a little video Joe Barrow honor
to be here he's just giving me a Jersey
[Applause]
so Joe I just told the coach we don't
normally do this but I'm doing it for
this team anybody would like to come
with me to the Oval Office
yes sir Trump starts talking about this
and all these guys behind Trump seem not
to have any interest in going to the
Oval Office and officers in the oval
it's a special place there's no place
like the Oval they come from all over
the world they have their own big
offices and everything's two guys that
your particular have known they say
there's no place like this so coach if
you'd like we can take whoever wants to
come to the Oval Office we'll take
pictures behind the resolute desk it's
been there a long time a lot of
presidents some good some not so good
but you got a good one now even though
they're trying to do it the greatest
economy we've ever had Joe yeah we got
anyway yeah very very funny video and
think thanks for bringing it to my
attention I appreciate that
how says with a $10 super chat just what
do you think you're doing Dave Dave I
really think I'm entitled to an answer
to that question of course anyone who
has seen Stanley Kubrick's great film
2001 a Space Odyssey or read Arthur C
Clark's great book 2001 a Space Odyssey
would immediately Dec 8 recognize the
reference and ma'am what a series of
books I actually I wish I could somehow
you know when there's a really great
series like the 2001 if there's four
books is it called the quadrilogy a lot
of people don't know that word what do I
sound like when there's such a great
series of books like that I wish I could
unreadable 2010 the third book I think
is 2060 one and then the fourth book in
the series three thousand one just
fantastic really really fantastic let's
see other voicemails that are coming in
let's see what else we've got here let's
take a listen to this next one hi Jared
big fan on the show oh this is a guy
whose real name is Troy York but he
calls din with pretty
bad voice-acting and pretends to be
different people hey I was wondering did
you hear or know that French president
Emmanuel Marquand was chased out of a
theatre by the yellow vest
movement and I didn't really see macron
had to leave a movie somewhere because
of a security issue and for his life um
I was wondering if you can report on
that ever um or Angela Merkel or her
unpopularity yeah we don't really do the
day-to-day like you know this this is
mostly in American politics show so like
the day-to-day you know what movie
Emmanuel macron went to that it's not
it's not really high very high on the
list of what we're doing but I I
appreciate the concern Troy and always
you know am riveted by by Troy's
voicemails let's see other people who
have called in let's see here take a
listen to this one hi David this has
been Taylor calling from New Orleans
Louisiana first want to say I appreciate
your show and your insight and all the
hard work and others that I follow like
Kyle and Sam cider and insider know
what's hilarious about calling him Sam
cider Sam grows apples Sam cedar is like
an expert in Apple growing and he knows
about all these different types of
apples and once he and I got into a
violent discussion about I believe
Granny Smith is the best apple and Sam
site er believes that other apples are
way better including ones that are only
available like between July 12 and 14 he
said to me he's like if you like Granny
Smith it's amazing the conversation we
had Sam cider said if you like Granny
Smith there's a particular Apple
available like in upstate New York
during five days in July which you
should get it thanks yeah thanks thanks
thanks Sam I'll look into that
but I love this idea of Sam cider
because Sam loves apples and knows a lot
of things about apples let's continue
but my question is do you have any
family members or maybe siblings or
friends
who are you no one of these cultists
trumpets no people I I have never known
my mom to be really into politics her
whole life but all of a sudden my uncle
her brother has gotten her on this
bandwagon and it has really affected our
friendship ya know I don't have that my
family is mostly Argentinean so I have
something that's arguably just as crazy
though which is there are people in my
family everybody's basically on the left
but I have people in my family who love
CFK Cristina and people who absolutely
despise her and so usually at most
family things in Argentina we have like
a no politics rule which kind of is lame
because you wouldn't you know politics
has been such a big thing in my entire
family growing up but it's gotten so bad
I'm actually gonna text Sam cedar about
the Sam site or thing this is so funny
someone left a voicemail calling you Sam
cider on ironically Roenick Lee which is
hilarious given your expertise in apples
and Apple related issues
we'll see what Sam thinks is Sam
streaming does anybody even know all
right we've got that off to Sam very
very good the Senate will resume
momentarily I will take questions via
super chat until that happens we are
just four oh my goodness can you imagine
how embarrassing it would be to me not
to you guys if we ended up four we Came
96% of the way to our goal and imagine
if we end up for new members shy let's
not do that
we have a very special impeachment
celebration coupon code impeach 50 and
if you use that when you sign up at join
pakman.com that number 96 will tick up
and off the screen as we hit
100 Ben Taylor says hey that was me oh
wait a second oh that's that's so funny
that was Ben who was calling that this
voicemail was from Ben and it has really
affected our friendship
I can't even the east have a
conversation with yeah my mom well Ben
debts that that's a big matzo ball
hanging out there that's that's for sure
let me say thanks to Jack Paige who is
new member number 97 97 we are inching
closer and closer to our goal of 100 new
members how random that Ben left this
voicemail when was this this morning oh
like almost 12 hours ago and then Ben is
also watching live right now that I'm
sure Ben is a very committed viewer of
the channel if on the same day that a
voicemail gets played you're also live
on stream I really appreciate that okay
we are anticipating the resumption of
festivities in the Senate just about any
moment here because they were scheduled
to be back five ten minutes ago actually
it's possible that Amy Klobuchar was not
able to find a comb for her salad and
ended up having to eat it with a fork
and that's taking maybe longer than we
expected but they should be back soon
and this could go at this I mean every
minute now that this delay extends is
probably another minute closer to
midnight or 1:00 a.m. that this is going
to go let's listen to a couple of other
voicemails let's take a listen to this
next one hey David I just saw something
concerning on your live stream about
your trip to the dentist where you said
that you needed in to do you a favor I
just want to make sure if you can
clarify that you said that you want
nothing you want nothing you want no
quid pro quo to tell the dentist to do
the right thing and that's the final
word from the host of the David Pakman
show
that's exactly right I called my dentist
yesterday we had a perfect phone call
and I did say when they said you know
I've not had dental insurance for 15
years because it dental insurance is
just not a good deal when you're a
business owner because it costs like 35
bucks a month but it usually has a
maximum year
benefit of like a thousand or $1200 so
when you take 35 times 12 that's you
know like four hundred and fifty dollars
the max benefit is a thousand you only
benefit from dental insurance if you're
paying for it yourself if you spend
exactly between four hundred and if they
in any case I've just been paying for my
cleanings out-of-pocket and the
occasional cavity so what I called my
dentist they said you know you don't
have dental insurance you're gonna owe
us ninety five bucks or whatever for the
cleaning I said that's fine I'm going to
need you to do me a favor though and the
call went very very much downhill from
there let me say thank you to Gregg P
Kosh
I believe I'm pronouncing that correctly
P Kosh because and Hilary Cowan Gregg
and Hilary are new members 98 Wow and 99
new members 98 and 99 we are just one
member away who wants to be member
number 100 of the impeach 50 promotion
does anybody want to be a new member
number 100 in fact I will say the
following anybody who ever becomes new
member number 100 I will give you a free
David Pakman show t-shirt of your choice
from our website
I will ship it anywhere in the world
reasonably speaking I guess yeah I lost
there's some weird place where we just
can't get it to free t-shirt Oh oh dear
that's weird oh I see it's the Google
Voice number ringing yes mmm whoever is
member number 100 with impeach 50 you'll
get a free t-shirt or any any clothing
item any swag item from the David Pakman
show store at Dave it's like david
pakman.com slash gear or slash stuff
something let's slash store I wish I
knew how my own website worked okay
thank you for two new soy boys on
youtube membership Peter Privitera Misti
Anderson and Michael stalker just to be
clear guys when I say free clothing item
I'm talking about website memberships at
join pakman.com I don't think it's
unrelated that I talked about
memberships and people became YouTube
members but we're talking about a join
pakman.com new member
number 100 whoever is number 100 will
get a free item free item from the David
Pakman show store Ryan Henry Dean says
do you have any current YouTube
producers aka 129 a month looking at
perks and trying to see examples of
existing producers names in the credits
oh you would only see that if you watch
the show on on broadcast television
that's the only place where the credits
actually show up I don't remember how we
have some producers I think we have like
two yeah I think we have two producers
yeah okay if you're just joining us any
minute any second now we are going to
get back to the Senate impeachment trial
there in a break it was a break for
dinner which was supposed to go from
6:35 p.m. Eastern time to 7:05 p.m.
Eastern Time we're almost 15 minutes
beyond that and we don't know what's
going on was there a food delivery that
was delayed was there I mean it's
anyone's guess what the delay is being
caused by but we're expecting them to
resume momentarily because of this delay
it's very likely very likely that this
will go until 1:00 a.m. or potentially
potentially even later I don't know how
late it's going to go okay all right I
think we have some folks who are all
going to be arguing that they are member
number 100 but unfortunately only one
person can be member number 100 because
they come in and order so I will
momentarily I just want to make sure
sometimes they even it the the emails
get all out of whack okay member number
100 is daeun genève Deanne genève is new
member number 100 today Dean
congratulations please get in touch by
e-mail at david pakman.com and let me
know what item size and color you want
from the david pakman show online store
and in addition to that let me know your
shipping address and we will get an item
out to you if you want a coffee mug or a
t-shirt or a hoodie or whatever we will
get it to you
and very very exciting and on that note
let's just up work carrying over the
membership goal so 100 was the was the
goal let's make it let's make it one two
three
how about one two three is the next is
the next goal for the impeachment fifty
new members let's take a listen to a
couple of the phone calls coming in on
c-span always a hoot and and just to be
clear do you find what's going on right
now a waste of time chain line of
defense that you could bring in a
smoking gun in a wooden matter and
they're gonna fight that bit just the
same way the Democrats would do it
because I'm here telling the truth about
politics enlighten has to change it's
alright it looks like they are
reconvening we are about to get started
again here could be a long one who knows
how long this this is going to go John
Roberts sitting in and asking a question
there we see Jerry Nadler Adam Schiff
looks poised to do something oh he is
coming to the podium we will hear again
from Adam Schiff Thank You mr. chief
justice just so senators have an idea of
the evening and expect to go about two
to two and a half hours I'll make a
presentation representative Lofgren from
California make a presentation I'll make
a final presentation and then we will be
done for the evening as an encouraging
voice told me keep it up but don't keep
it up too long right so we will do our
best not to keep it up too long
that applies to um I'm going to turn to
the bar of the chronology that picks up
right after that July 25th call and walk
through the increasingly explicit
pressure campaign waged on Ukraine in
order to get president Trump's
deliverable the investigations meant to
tarnish his opponent and help his
reelection now remember by the end of
July Ukraine was aware of
Trump's requests for investigation to
help his political efforts and had come
to know that President Trump put a
freeze on security assistance so this is
by the end of July they also clearly
understood that President Trump was
withholding an oval office meeting until
those investigations were announced both
were very critical to Ukraine as a sign
of us support and as a matter of their
national security and their national
security of course implicates our
national security in the weeks after the
July 25th call president Trump's
hand-picked representatives escalated
their efforts to get the public
announcement of the investigations from
Ukraine so let's go through this
step-by-step because the three weeks
following the July 25th call tell so
much about this pressure scheme let's
start with July 26 on July 26 so this is
the day after the call ambassador of
Volker sends a text message to Giuliani
and that text message says hi mr. mayor
you may have heard the president had a
great call with ukrainian President
yesterday exactly the right messages as
we discussed please send dates when you
will be in Madrid I am seeing Yair Mach
tomorrow morning he will come to you in
Madrid thanks for your help Kurt so here
we are the day after that call as my
colleague demonstrates this same day so
July 26 of the date of that second
infamous call between President Trump
this time in Gordon Sandlin that you
heard the diplomat David Holmes
described so that's same day July 26
that we're talking about right now where
there's this text message now of course
in that July 25th call the president
wants to connect Rudy Giuliani with the
presidents of Ukraine and his people and
so this is a follow-up where ambassador
Volker
is saying to Giuliani it was a great
call with Ukraine president exactly the
right messages as we discussed and we
know of course those messages were the
need to do this political investigation
please send dates when you'll be in
Madrid I'm seeing here mark tomorrow
morning he will come to you and Madrid
so here is ambassador Volker one of the
three amigos
following up arranging this meeting
[Music]
between Giuliani and the Ukrainians
Gianni replied setting a meeting in
Europe with presidents Lewinsky's top
aide for the very next week quote I will
arrive on August 1 and until 5:00 he
wrote now remember on July 22nd so a few
days before this and before the call
ambassador Volcker had connected
Giuliani originally with the air MOC and
they agreed to meet so this is a
follow-up you have that arrangement
being made by Volker and Giuliani before
the call then you have the call and now
you have the follow-up to arrange the
meeting in Madrid and so they do meet
and rid Madrid this is August 2nd under
a year mock zelinsky's top aide flew to
Madrid meets with Rudy Giuliani who they
know represented the president's
interests both Giuliani and the air mock
walk away from this meeting in Madrid
clearly understanding that a White House
meeting is linked to zelinsky's
announcement of the investigations in
separate conversations with Giuliani in
the air mock after this Madrid meeting
Volker said he learned that Giuliani
wanted the Ukrainians to issue a
statement including specific mentions of
the two investigations that the
president wanted according to ambassador
Volkers testimony Yair Mach told him
that his meeting with Giuliani was very
good and immediately added that the
Ukrainians asked for a White House
meeting during the week of September
16th Yermak presses Volker on the White
House meeting dates saying that he was
waiting for confirmation maybe you know
the date this is a recurrent theme that
we've seen through the text messages and
other documents and that is the
recurrent request for this meeting the
pressing for this meeting by Ukrainians
because it was so important to them
Giuliani's objective was clear two
ambassadors Volker and Sandlin who took
over communications with the air Mac
here's ambassador Sunland I first
communicated with mr. Giuliani and early
August several months later mr. Giuliani
emphasized that the president wanted a
public statement from president Solinsky
committing Ukraine to look into the
corruption issues mr. Giuliani
specifically mentioned the 2016 election
including the DNC server and burry smih
as to topics of importance to the
president Giuliani exerted significant
influence in this process in fact when
an August 4th uremic inquired again
about the presidential meeting
ambassador Volk returned not to the
National Security Council staff or to
the State Department to arrange it and
follow-up
he turns to Giuliani again Volcker told
year mock that he would speak with
Giuliani later that day and would call
the Ukrainian president's aide afterward
Volcker then texts Giuliani to ask about
the Madrid meeting and to set up the
call that he had mentioned the air mock
Giuliani replies that the meeting with
Yair Mach was excellent and that he
would call later
phone records obtained by the
committee's show a 16 minute call on
August 5th between ambassador Volker and
Giuliani ambassador Volker then tech
seer mock I and Ray had a good long talk
with Rudi call anytime Kurt separately
Volker told ambassador Sandlin Giuliani
was happy with that meeting and it looks
like things are turning around a
reference to Volkers hope that
satisfying Giuliani would break down
president Trump's reservations
concerning Ukraine but things had not
turned around by the end of that first
week of August by August 7th the aid was
still on hold and there had been no
movement on setting a date for the White
House meeting ambassador of Volcker then
reaches out to Giuliani to try to get
things moving
ambassador Volker
guiliani to recommend that he report to
the boss
meaning President Trump about his
meeting with Yair Mach in Madrid
specifically he wrote this is Volker
writing to Giuliani hi Rudy hope you
made it back safely
let's meet if you're coming to DC and
would be good if you could convey
results of your meeting in Madrid to the
boss so we can get a firm date for the
visit so this is ambassador of Volker
falling up Giuliani Giuliani's met with
the top aide to the president of Ukraine
in Madrid and he wants Giuliani to
convey to the boss to Trump how good
that meeting in Madrid was about the
investigations so they can get the
president of Ukraine in the door at the
White House think about how unusual this
is this is the president's personal
lawyer who's on this personal mission on
behalf of his client to get these
investigations in Ukraine the president
of Ukraine can't get in the door of the
Oval Office and who are they going to or
the going of the Security Council know
or they going the State Department no
they tried all that they're going to the
president's personal lawyer does that
sound like a official policy to try to
fight corruption why would you go
outside of the normal channel to do that
you wouldn't know you go to your
personal attorney who's on a personal
mission that he admits is not foreign
policy when your objective has nothing
to do with policy when your objection
when your objective is a corrupt one now
what does that mean to have a corrupt
objective well it means an illicit one
it means a permissible one it means one
that furthers your own interest at the
cost of the national interest
the willingness to to break the law
like the impoundment Control Act by
withholding aid is indicative of that
corrupt purpose the lengths the
president would go not in furtherance of
US policy but against US policy not even
a difference on policy at all the mere
pursuit of personal interest the pursuit
of an illegal effort to get foreign
interference is the very embodiment of a
corrupt intent so here we are August 7th
and Volcker is saying Rudy if you're
coming to DC let's get together it'd be
good if you can talk to the boss because
we can't get a meeting other way around
that time ambassador Volcker received a
text message from Yair mock who asked
him and this is your mock asking Volcker
hi Kurt how are you do you have some
news about the White House meeting date
and volkl responds not yet I texted Rudy
earlier to make sure he weighs in
following your meeting
Gordon meaning Sandlin should be
speaking with the president on Friday we
are pressing this so there is gorgeous
Islands pressing this this is the man
you've heard from already Gordon Sandlin
the man who says it was absolutely a
quid pro quo you've asked about a quid
pro quo there was a quid pro quo about
this White House meeting this is what
they're talking about right here Gordon
will be speaking with the president on
Friday we are pressing this bastard
Volkers contact with Giuliani spurred a
flurry of communications the patterns of
calls from August 8th strongly suggest
Giuliani's attempting to call the White
House to speak to a senior White House
official left a message then had a four
minute call with an official later that
night we don't know from the call
records who that White House official
was but recall that Giuliani has
publicly stated that when he spoke to
the White House he usually spoke to
President Trump his client
also in August 8th the Ehrmann text
Volker that he had some news
Baskerville ker replies that he can talk
then and bass revoke our updates
Giuliani in a text the next day Volker
says to Giuliani in the text hi mr.
mayor had a good chat with the air Mach
last night he was pleased with your
phone call mentioned he's referring to
president Solinsky here making a
statement can we all get on the phone to
make sure I advised and here he's
referring to president Solinsky
correctly as to what he should be saying
I want to make sure we get this done
right so here
August 9th there's an effort by Volcker
to make sure that they get this
statement right about the investigations
because if they can't get the statement
right he ain't gonna get in the door of
the Oval Office it also makes clear who
he's exactly in charge of this and
that's Rudy Giuliani ambassador Volkers
checking with Rudy Giuliani about what
he should vice-president Solinsky and we
know that Giuliani is taking his orders
from President Trump text messages and
call records obtained by the committee's
show that ambassador Volcker and
Giuliani connected by phone twice around
noon on August 9th for several minutes
each following the calls with Giuliani
ambassador Volcker created a 3-way group
chat using whatsapp that included
himself ambassador Sunland and Yair Mach
a master Volcker initiated the chat
around 2:20 that day and this is Volcker
chatting with song hland and the air
muck it's a 3-way chat and Volker says
hi Andre
meaning air Mach we have all consulted
here including Rudy could you do a call
later today or tomorrow your afternoon
time and Salman says I have a call
scheduled to 3:00 p.m. Eastern for the
three of us will call
call records obtained by the committee
show that an August 9th pastor Solomon
twice connected with phone lines
associated with the White House once in
the early afternoon for about 18 minutes
and once in the late afternoon for about
two minutes
we know that ambassador sunland had
direct access to President Trump after
all this activity ambassador sullen and
Volker thought they had a breakthrough
finally a breakthrough minutes after
this call which was likely with Tim
Morrison about a possible date for the
White House meeting ambassador of
Volcker and Salomon discussed the
agreement they believed they'd reached
and starts with Sandlin in this text
message
Morrison ready to get dates as soon as
year mock confirms Volker says excellent
how did you sway him not sure I did says
Sandlin
I think POTUS really wants the
deliverable well we know what that
deliverable is it's the political
investigations Volker says but does he
know that and Soglin says yep clearly
lots of convos meaning conversations
going on and Volker says okay and that's
good it's coming from two separate
sources master Solomon told the
committees that the deliverable required
by President Trump was a press statement
from President Solinsky committing to do
the investigations into the Biden's and
the allegation of Ukraine election
interference the president Trump
mentioned on July 25th but Tim Morrison
testified that he didn't know anything
about the deliverable he was just
involved in trying to schedule the White
House meeting which everyone wanted to
schedule is a sign of support for
president Solinsky and our ally Ukraine
but Trump's agents wouldn't just accept
Ukraine's word for it ambassador Sandlin
then recommended to ambassador Volcker
that year amok share a draft a draft of
the press statement to ensure that the
statement would comport with the
president's expectations so here on
August 9th so we're still less than two
weeks after the July 25th call
or about I guess we're about two weeks
Sandlin says in this message to avoid
misunderstandings might be helpful to
ask Andre for a draft statement
parentheses embargoed so that we can see
exactly what they propose to cover even
though Z referring to Solinsky does a
live presser they can still summarize in
a brief statement thoughts and Volker
says agree at his deposition ambassador
song once said that he suggested
reviewing a written summary of the
statement because he was concerned that
president szalinski would say whatever
he would say in live television and it
still wouldn't be good enough for Rudy
slash the president unquote the air mock
intern was concerned that the
announcement would still not result
result in the coveted White House
meeting on August 10th year mock texted
Volker attempting to schedule White
House meeting before the Ukrainian
president made a public statement in
support of the investigations into
purissima and the 2016 election so he
could see what's going on here the
president and his agent Giuliani they
want this public statement the
investigations before they'll give a
date and the Ukrainians want a date
before they have to commit to making
public they're gonna do the
investigations and so you've had this
standoff where each is trying to get the
deliverable first but there's no debate
about what the deliverable is on either
side there's no debate about the quid
pro quo here you give me this I'll give
you that you give me the White House
meeting I'll give you the public
announcement the investigation into your
political rival no no you give me the
announcement the investigation into my
arrival and then I'll give you the
meeting the only debate here is about
which comes first
so August 10th your mock text Volker I
think it's possible to make this
declaration I mention all these things
which we discussed yesterday but it will
be logic to do after we receive a
confirmation of tape we inform about
data visit about our expectations and
our guarantees for future visit let's
discuss it
ambassador Volker responded that he
agreed but that first they would have to
iron out a statement and use that to get
a date after which president Solinsky
would give the statement the two decided
to have a call the next day and to
include a bastard Sunland Yair mock
texts ambassador of Volker excellent
once we have a date we will call for a
press briefing announcing upcoming visit
and outlining vision for the reboot of
us Ukraine relationship including a
mother among other things burr yzma and
election meddling in the investigations
Yarmouk was also in direct contact with
Ambassador Solomon regarding this
revised approach in fact he sent to
master song in the same text message
ambassador Soglin kept the leadership of
the State Department in the loop on
August 10th he told a baskerville cur
that he had reported to tea all
regretful counselor of the Department of
State who saw and testified frequently
consulted with secretary Pompeo sana
wrote to Volker i briefed ulrich all
good
so Ulrich is in the loop Sandlin and
Volker continued to pursue the statement
from szalinski on the investigations the
next day ambassador Sandlin emails Brett
bull and Lisa Kenna the State
Department's executive secretary about
efforts to secure a public statement and
a big presser from president Solinsky
Sandlin hoped it might quote make the
boss happy enough to authorize an
investigation an invitation after first
being evasive on the topic secretary
Pompeo has subsequently acknowledged
that he listened in on the July 25th
call now since he was on the call
Pompeyo must have understood what would
make the boss that is the president's
happy enough to schedule a White House
meeting again everyone was in the loop
on August 11th ambassador of Volker sent
Giuliani a text message
this is Volker 2 Giuliani hi Rudy we
have heard back from Andre again they
are writing the statement now and will
send it to us can you talk for five
minutes before noon today and Juliana
says yes just call that's August 11th on
the next day August 12 your mock sent
ambassador Volker an initial version of
the draft statement by text notably as
we saw earlier this statement from the
Ukrainians doesn't explicitly mention
burry ISM Abidin or 2016 election
investigations that the president has
been seeking so you could see what's
going on here now there was this game of
chicken you go first no we'll go first
you give us the date we'll give you the
sapin no you give us the statement we'll
give you the date and now realizing ok
they've got to give the statement first
Ukraine tries to give them a generic
statement that doesn't really go into
specifics about these investigations and
why you can imagine why the craniums
don't want to have to go out in public
and say they're gonna do these
investigations because they're not
stupid because they understood this
would pull them right into US
presidential politics because it was
intended to which isn't in Ukraine's
interest it's not in our interest either
and Ukraine understood that and so they
resisted first they resisted having to
do the public statement and then they
wanted to make sure they get the
deliverable and then when they had to
make the statement they didn't want to
be specific for one thing for another
thing this was what szalinski campaigned
on he was gonna fight corruption he was
gonna end political investigations so he
didn't want to be specific
so he sends the statement that doesn't
have the specific references and Besser
Volcker explained during his testimony
that was not what Giuliani was
requesting and it would not satisfy
Giuliani or Donald Trump now presumably
if the president was interested in
corruption that statement would have
been enough but all he was interested in
was an investigation or an announcement
of an investigation into his rival and
this debunked theory about 2016 now the
conversation that Volcker referred to in
his earlier testimony took place on the
morning of August 13th when Giuliani
made clear that the specific
investigations related to burr asthma
code for Biden's and the 2016 election
had to be included in order to get the
White House meeting so the Americans
sent back to the Ukrainian top aide a
revised draft that includes now the two
investigations and you seen the
side-by-side this was then the essence
of the quid pro quo regarding the
meeting and this direction came from
President Trump here is how ambassador
Sunland put it mister Giuliani's
requests were a quid pro quo for
arranging a White House visit for
President Solinsky mr. Giuliani demanded
that Ukraine make a public statement
announcing the investigations of the
2016 election DNC server and barrese my
mr. Giuliani was expressing the desires
of the President of the United States
and we knew these investigations were
important to the president now according
to witness testimony as you might
imagine Ukrainian officials were very
uncomfortable with a draft that Giuliani
Volcker and Sungmin were negotiated they
understood that the statement was the
deliverable that President Trump wanted
but yielding to present Trump's demands
would in essence force president
Solinsky to break his promise to the
Ukrainian people to root out corruption
because politically motivated
investigations are a hallmark of the
kind of corruption that Ukraine has been
plagued with in the past
mr. Yarmuth tried to get some
confirmation that the requested
investigations were legitimate in
response to the draft statement Yair
Mach asks Volcker quote whether any Kerr
request had ever been made by the US to
investigation election interference in
2016 in other words whether any
requested may had been made by any
official US law enforcement agency
through formal channels as you would
expect if it were a legitimate request
ambassador Volcker tried to find a
satisfactory answer on August 15th
Volkers assistant asked Deputy Assistant
assistant secretary George Kent whether
there was any precedent for such a
request for investigations at his
deposition Kent testified that if you're
asking me have we ever gone to the
Ukrainians and asked them to investigate
a prosecute individuals for political
reasons the answer is I hope we haven't
and we shouldn't because that goes
against everything that we are trying to
promote in the post-soviet states for
the last 28 years which is the promotion
of the rule of law
the next day we're now on August 16th in
a conversation with ambassador Bill
Taylor the US ambassador in Kiev and
pastor Taylor stepped in when ambassador
Jovanovic was pushed out Taylor quote
amplified the same theme and told Kent
that quote Yair Mach was very
uncomfortable with the idea of
Investigations and suggested it should
be done officially and put in writing as
a result it became clear to Canton
mid-august that Ukraine was being
pressured to conduct politically
motivated investigations Kent told
ambassador Taylor that's wrong and we
shouldn't be doing it as a matter of US
policy ambassador Volcker claimed that
he stopped pursuing the statement from
the Ukrainians around this time because
of the concerns raised by zelinsky's Aid
at his deposition and despite all of his
efforts to secure statement announcing
these very specific political
investigations desired by the president
ambassador Volcker testified that he
agreed with the airmax concerns and
advised him that making those specific
references was not a good idea because
making those statements might look like
it would play into our domestic politics
without specific references to the
politically damaging investigations that
Trump demanded the agreement just
wouldn't work Ukraine did not release
the statement and in turn the white
house meeting was not scheduled as it
turns out
ambassador Sandlin and Volcker did not
achieve the breakthrough after all
now let's go into what finally breaks
the law Jim because that involves the
military aid with efforts to trade a
White House meeting for a press
statement announcing the investigations
temporarily scuttled Sandlin of vogue or
go back to the drawing board on August
19th Ambassador Sandlin told the volcker
that he drove the larger issue home with
the Ermac president solinsky's top aide
particularly that this was now bigger
than a White House meeting bigger than
just the White House meeting and was
about the relationship per se the
relationship per se not just about the
meeting anymore it's about everything
it's about everything by this time in
late August the Holden security
assistance had been in place for more
than a month and there was still no
credible explanation offered by the
White House
despite some like ambassador song and
repeatedly asking there were no
interagency meetings since July 31st and
the Defense Department had withdrawn its
assurances that it could even comply
with the law which indeed it couldn't
every agency in the administration
opposed the hold as the Government
Accountability Office confirmed
concerned DoD and OMB officials had been
right that the president's holding of
the aid was an unlawful act but
President Trump was not budging at the
same time despite the persistent efforts
of numerous people President Trump
refused to schedule the coveted White
House visit for president Solinsky until
the investigations were announced that
would benefit his campaign here is what
ambassador Sunland said about the hold
on funds and it's linked to the
politically motivated investigations in
Ukraine in the absence of any credible
explanation for the suspension of aid I
later came to believe that the
resumption of security aid would not
occur until there was a public statement
from Ukraine committing to the
investigations of the 2016 elections
and barista as mr. Giuliani had demanded
from the embassy in keeve david holmes
reached the same conclusion a conclusion
as simple as two plus two equals four
mr. Holmes you have testified that by
late August you has you had a clear
impression that the security assistance
hold was somehow connected to the
investigations that President Trump
wanted how did you conclude how did you
make reach that clear conclusion sir
we've been hearing about the
investigation since March months before
and we've been president szalinski had
received a letter congratulatory letter
from the president saying he'd be
pleased to meet him
following his inauguration in May and we
hadn't even to get that meeting and then
the security hold came up with no
explanation and I'd be surprised if any
of the Ukrainians you said earlier we
discussed earlier you know sophisticated
people when they received no explanation
for why that hold was in place they
would have drawn that conclusion because
the investigations were still being
pursued correct and the hold was still
remaining without explanation correct so
this to you was the only logical
conclusion that you could reach correct
sort of like two plus two equals four
exactly Salman explained the predicament
he believed he faced with a hold on aid
to Ukraine
as my other State Department colleagues
have testified this security aid was
critical to Ukraine's defense and should
not have been delayed I expressed this
view to many during this period but my
goal at the time was to do it was
necessary to get the aid release to
break the logjam
I believe that the public statement we
had been discussing for weeks was
essential to advancing that goal you
know I really regret that the Ukrainians
were placed in that predicament but I do
not regret doing what I could to try to
break the logjam and to solve the
problem on August 22nd ambassador
Solomon tried to break that logjam as he
put it regarding both the Security
Assistance hold and the White House
meeting ambassador Solomon described
those efforts in his public testimony
let's listen to him again in preparation
for the September 1 Warsaw meeting I
asked secretary Pompeo whether a
face-to-face conversation between Trump
and zalenski would help to break the
logjam
alright let's pause briefly just to
check back in and see what's going on we
are on impeachment trial day three part
two we are calling this Adam Schiff said
at about 7:10 that they have about two
and a half hours to go of presentations
as he called them tonight meaning with
this will and somewhere between 9:30 and
10:00 p.m. I want to get to a few super
chats that are coming in there are going
to be dozens and dozens of hours so I
hope you'll indulge me if we see what's
on your mind a little bit rather than
just listening and watching through this
endlessly so any oh I'll catch up on
Super chats momentarily let me say a few
thank-yous Stewart lot spite is a new
David Pakman show member number one zero
one car Carl Weigel is new member number
one zero two and Eric's pour Borg is new
member number one zero three we are at
103 out of our target of 123 new members
the coupon code is impeached
d and join pakman.com is the place to
sign up let me get caught up on super
chats here and see where exactly I left
off okay Hannah Laura Clemmensen says
David I just made it home through a
blizzard am i the hundredth new member
no Hana Laura the memberships the
hundred hundredth new member happened
about a half hour before you said that
and the memberships are at joined
pakman.com so i unfortunately you're not
new member number 100 John McKinney says
Allan Lichtman claims that Democrats
shouldn't worry about unity he claims it
only counts for the party controlling
the White House Democrats don't control
the White House what do you think yeah
with every I've interviewed Allan
Lichtman with everything Allan Lichtman
says my view tends to be he's sort of
right but if you go fully to what he
says to its full conclusion you often
end up with with things that don't pass
the sniff test but he's always sort of
right
and we'll talk about the unity issue
maybe tomorrow or or even on the Friday
show Hana Laura Clemmensen also adds
pronunciation guide Honolulu Lulu
replaced with Laura Hana Laura okay all
right well I think I did I think I did
that correctly
I appreciate it very much super chats
are the dollar sign at the bottom of the
chat window if you're watching on a
desktop computer over the video window
if you're watching on mobile you click
it you send your message and then it'll
pop up right over there I will get back
to I will do more Super chats
momentarily and let's get back to what
Adams - Adam shifts presentation as he
calls it what would favorably impressed
Donald Trump what Donald Trump be
favorably impressed if president
Solinsky were to tell him about this new
corruption court or new legislation in
Nerada or how negotiations with the
Russians were going or how they're
bringing about defense reform at any of
those things ever come up in any of
these text messages any of these emails
any of these phone calls any of these
conversations of course not of course
not
there was only one thing that was gonna
favorably impress President Trump in
Warsaw and that is if zalenski told him
to his face I'm gonna do these political
investigations I don't want to do them
you know I don't want to do them I've
resisted doing them but I'm at war with
Russia and I can't wait anymore I can't
wait anymore
I'm sure that would have impressed
Donald Trump but the meeting but to the
between the two presidents never
happened in Warsaw President Trump
canceled the trip at the last moment
before Boulton left keeve ambassador
Taylor asked for a private meeting
ambassador Taylor explained that he was
extremely concerned about the hold and
security assistance he described the
meeting to us during his testimony near
the end of ambassador Bolton's visit I
asked to meet him privately during which
I expressed to him my serious concern
about the withholding of military
assistance to Ukraine while the
Ukrainians were defending their country
from Russian aggression I want to let
you guys know that it's being it's being
widely reported that during atom shifts
earlier presentation 21 Republicans
weren't even in the Senate chamber now
you know we've been joking about the
rules they're allowed water and milk and
nothing else are flavored milks allowed
we've been joking around 21 of the 53
Republicans missed large portions of
Adams shifts earlier testimony the rules
say they are supposed to be there they
are supposed to be adjudicating the fate
of the President of the United States
and they were missing 40% 39% of
Republicans were missing for huge
portions of this of course it's a
foregone conclusion that they're going
to vote to acquit we know that but can't
they at least pretend to be doing what
they're supposed to be doing 40% of
Republicans missed a huge portion of the
presentation
how will they now decide whether to a
quitter convict oh right it never
mattered they were always going to vote
to acquit from the State Department if
you'd like to know what John Bolton had
in mind when he thought
that szalinski could favorably impress
the president in Warsaw we can find that
out too just for the asking and a
document called a subpoena
so Taylor sends that cable August 29th
the State Department
speaking of which and people want to
just see the stream and nothing else
there's a million streams where you can
see that people have been noticing that
we barely get a shot of what's going on
in the Senate we have this shot which is
just the close-up of the speaker the the
person speaking I want to be clear the
speaker could mean something else and
then there's a more zoomed out shot
where you see Justice John Roberts and
sort of the people at the front and the
Democratic and Republican desks c-span
is not controlling the cameras as far as
we recently heard c-span asked Mitch
McConnell to control the cameras they
have plenty of cameras we could get a
much more nuanced and and and varied
production of this Mitch McConnell is
controlled the Senate that the Senate
Majority Leader is controlling the
cameras and we would notice that there
is empty seats if they actually allowed
c-span to control the cameras and so
that's why it took a reporter in the
room to tweet for us to learn that 21
Republican senators were gone during
Adams shifts earlier it's all I mean
it's it's a vicious circle of of quid
pro quo
so you scratch my back status quo
nonsense and that and and it - I mean
rigged I guess is just the right word
rigged kind of encompasses all of it if
it matters to us we should care about
the fact that in 1994 when we asked them
to give up their nuclear weapons that
they had inherited from the Soviet Union
and they didn't want to give them up and
we were worried about proliferation we
said hey if you give them up which you
don't want to do because you're worried
the Russians might invade if you give
them up we will help assure your
territorial integrity we made that
commitment I hope we care about that
I hope we care about that because they
did give them up and you know what just
what they feared took place the Russians
moved across their border and they
remain occupying part of Ukraine that's
the word of America we gave and we're
breaking that word why for help with a
political campaign bastard Taylor was
exactly right that's crazy it's worse
than crazy it's repulsive it's repugnant
it breaks our word and to do it in the
name of these corrupt investigations is
also contrary to to everything we
espouse around the world I used to be
part of a commission in the house on
democracy assistance where we would meet
with parliamentarians and I know my
Senate colleagues do much the same thing
and we would we would urge our
colleagues to observe the rule of law
not to engage in political
investigations and prosecutions I don't
know how we make that argument now I
don't know how we look our allies or
these burgeoning democracies in the face
our fellow parliamentarians that make
that argument how do we make that
argument now
now testimony indicated that Secretary
of Pompeo eventually carried that cable
into the White House but there's no
evidence that those national security
current concerns that they don't want
you to see were able to outweigh the
president's personal interest in his
getting foreign help in his reelection
campaign there's no evidence at all now
we get to August 28th Politico was the
first to publicly report publicly report
the president Trump had implemented a
hold on nearly 400 million of US
military assistance to Ukraine that had
been appropriated by Congress now that
the worst kept secret was public
Ukrainian officials immediately
expressed their alarm and concern to the
American counterparts as witnesses
explained the Ukrainians had two serious
concerns one of course was the aid
itself which was vital to their ability
to fight off Russia but in addition they
were worried about the symbolism of the
hold that it's signaled to Russia and
Vladimir Putin that the United States
was wavering in its support for Ukraine
witnesses testified that this was a
division that Russia could and would
exploit to drive further wedge between
the United States and Ukraine to its
advantage
this second concern was why likely why
Ukrainian officials had wanted the hold
to remain a secret in the first place
because it would add to the negative
impact Ukraine if the hold itself became
public it's bad enough that the
president the United States put a hold
on their aid it was going to be far
worse if it became public as indeed it
did Andrei year mock the same szalinski
aide sent ambassador Volker a link to
the political story Politico story and
then texted need to talk with you other
Ukrainian officials also expressed
concerns to baskerville Kerr that the
Ukrainian Ukrainian government was being
singled out and penalized for some
reason well what do we think that reason
was why were they being singled out
why was that country be singled out that
was the one country that this president
could leave her for help against an
opponent he feared
that's why Ukraine was being singled out
lever I like that versus August 29th
year mock also contacted ambassador
Taylor yaar max said the Ukrainians were
very concerned about the hold of
military assistance he said that he and
other Ukrainian officials would be
willing to travel to Washington to
explain to US officials the importance
of this assistance ambassador Taylor who
was on the ground in Ukraine explained
the Ukrainian viewpoint and frankly
their desperation in September the
Minister of Defense for example came to
me I would use the word desperate to
figure out why the assistance was being
held he thought that perhaps if he went
to Washington to talk to you who to talk
to them to Secretary of Defense to talk
to the president he would be able to
find out and and reassure provide
whatever answer was necessary to have
that assistance released without any
official explanation for the hold
American officials could provide little
reassurance to their Ukrainian
counterparts it has been publicly
reported that President Trump secretary
Esper and secretary Pompeo met in late
August and that they all implored the
President to release the aid but
President Trump continued to refuse to
release the aid as of August 30th the
president was clearly directing OMB to
continue the hold on security assistance
in documents reviewed by just security
but withheld from the Congress by OMB on
the president's instructions OMB
official Michael Duffy emailed DoD
controller Elaine McCusker that there is
quote clear direction from POTUS to
continue the whole so here we are
August 30th
a month after that July 25th call aids
still being withheld Ukrainians still
holding on still not willing to
capitulate not willing to violate
zelinsky's whole campaign pledge about
not engaging in corrupt investigations
that same day August 30th the Republican
Senator Ron Johnson spoke with
ambassador Solomon to express his
concern about President Trump's decision
to withhold military assistance to
Ukraine senator Johnson described that
call in an interview with The Wall
Street Journal according to his senator
Johnson ambassador Sandlin told him that
if Ukraine would commit to quote get to
the bottom of what happened in 2016 if
President Trump has that confidence then
he'll release the military spending
senator Johnson added at that suggestion
I winced my reaction was oh god I don't
want to see those two things combined
the next day August 31st senator Johnson
spoke by phone with President Trump
regarding the decision to withhold aid
to Ukraine according to The Wall Street
Journal president Trump denied the quid
pro quo that Senator Johnson had learned
of from ambassador Sandlin at the same
time however President Trump refused to
authorize senator Johnson to tell
Ukrainian officials on his upcoming trip
to keeve that the aide would be
forthcoming the message that ambassador
sunland communicated to senator Johnson
mirrored that used by President Trump
during the July 25th call with President
Solinsky in which President Trump twice
asked ukrainian leader to get to the
bottom of it including in connection to
an investigation into the debunked
conspiracy theory of ukrainian
interference in the 2016 election it
also mirrored the language of the text
message that ambassador of Volcker sent
to president solinsky's aid just before
the July 25th call indeed despite the
president's self-serving denials the
message was clear
President Trump wanted the investigation
and he would withhold not one but two
acts vested in him by the power of his
office in order to get them now begins
September September first president was
supposed to go to Warsaw as we know but
he doesn't go to Warsaw Mike Pence goes
to Warsaw Jennifer Williams special
advisor to the vice president for Europe
and Russia learned of the change and the
president's travel plans on August 29th
the vice president's national security
adviser asked that the requests to vice
president pence for an update on the
status of the security assistance that
had just been publicly revealed in
Politico and would be a critical issue
during the bilateral meeting between the
vice president and president Solinsky in
Warsaw the delegation arrives in Warsaw
and gathers in the hotel room to brief
vice president pence before he met with
ukrainian president national security
adviser bolton led the meeting as
williams described it advisors in the
room quote agreed on the need to get a
final decision on security assistance as
soon as possible
so that it could be implemented before
the end of the year but vice president
pence did not have authority from the
president to release the aide ambassador
Soglin also attended that briefing at
the end of it he expressed concern
directly to vice president pence about
the security assistance being held until
the Ukrainians announced the very same
politically motivated investigations at
the heart of the scheme you mentioned
that you also had a conversation with
vice president pence before his meeting
with President Solinsky in Warsaw and
that you raised the concern you had as
well that the security assistance was
being withheld because of the
president's desire to get a commitment
from szalinski to pursue these political
investigations it's quite interesting to
see a skilled orator like Adam Schiff
take pieces of the house interviews
testimony I guess we would call it and
then weave it together to tell this
now in the Senate for the Senate let's
just take a brief pause from what's
going on we will get back to it I
promise you you won't miss anything that
will inform the eventual outcome of
these proceedings if you understand what
I mean John McKinney sent a super chat
saying if Republicans lose in November
of 2020 will Republicans blame Donald
Trump for their loss as well if Trump
loses and Republicans lose there will be
many opportunistic Republicans who will
blame Trump for their losses if
Republicans lose and Trump dozens you
may see the people that lose blame Trump
but the Republican Party for as long as
Donald Trump is the president is not
going to blame the president you can you
can be absolutely assured of that I'll
continue to take super chats as they
come in I don't know if there is going
to be another break before the end of
this Adam Schiff saying a little while
ago that they had about two and a half
hours to go which puts us somewhere
between 9:30 and 10:00 p.m. Eastern Time
and it remains a question whether there
will be another break or not we also are
up to a hundred and three of our goal of
a hundred and twenty three new members
anybody using that code up there impeach
50 when you sign up at join pakman.com
you will literally move this blue bar
across the screen and I will also thank
you live which is very exciting for some
people I must say beating the Warsaw
meeting with vice president Pence
ambassador Solomon quickly pulled aside
Andre year mock zelinsky's top aide and
informed him that the aid would not be
forthcoming until Ukraine publicly
announced the two investigations that
President Trump wanted so here we are
after the meeting right after the
meeting they're still in Warsaw and
szalinski pulls aside his Ukrainian
counterpart Yair Mach and explains the
aid is not coming until the
investigations are announced
based on my previous communication with
secretary Pompeo I felt comfortable
sharing my concerns with mr. your Mac it
was a very very brief pull-aside
conversation that happened within a few
seconds I told mr. your Mac that I
believe that the resumption of US aid
would likely not occur until Ukraine
took some kind of action on the public
statement that we had been discussing
for many weeks I mean let's let that
sink in for a minute - you've heard my
colleagues at the other table say
Ukrainians felt no pressure there's no
evidence they felt any pressure of
course we've already had testimony about
how they did feel pressure and they
didn't want to be drawn into this
political campaign and you saw over and
over and these text messages emails no
you go first you announce no you go
first
and we're supposed to believe they felt
no pressure and there it is it breaks
out into the open the military is being
a distinct withheld and there's a
connection between the holding of the
military aid and these investigations
and the first thing they're asking about
they send the copy of the article what's
happening with this aid they're ready to
come to DC to plead for the aid they go
to Warsaw they meet with the vice
president it's the first question is the
aid and what happens after that meeting
now that's a big meeting by the way with
the vice president the Ukrainian
delegation it's not like in front of all
those people the vice president's just
going to bring it up and so song that
goes up to his counterpart right after
that on the sidelines of that meeting
and he says basically you ain't getting
the money until you do the
investigations and we're to believe they
felt no pressure folks they're at war
they're at war and they're being told
you're not getting four hundred million
in aid you need unless you do what the
president wants and what the president
wants are these two investigations if
you don't believe that's pressure that's
four hundred million dollars worth of
pressure I got a bridge I want to sell
you
it's hard for us to put ourselves in the
Ukrainians position
I mean imagine the eastern third of our
country were occupied by an enemy force
and we're beholding to another country
for military aid and they're saying
you're not gonna get it until you do
what we want do you think we'd feel
pressured
I think we'd feel pressured and that's
exactly the situation the Ukrainians
were in now you've heard my counsels the
other council say before well but they
say they don't feel pressure like
they're gonna admit they were being
shaken down by the Prez of the United
States you think they feel pressure now
you should see what kind of pressure
they feel if they admitted that Tim
Morrison the NSC official witnessed the
conversation between Sunland and the air
mock from across the room and
immediately thereafter received a
summary from bastards omlette he
reported the substance of that
conversation to his boss ambassador
Bolton who told Morrison to consult with
the lawyers go talk to the lawyers you
know if if you keep getting told you got
to go talk to the lawyers there's a
problem if things are perfect you don't
get told go talk to the lawyers time and
time again
Morrison confirmed that he did talk to
the lawyers in part to ensure there was
a record of what ambassador song land
was doing that record exists within the
White House would you like me to read
you that record I'd be happy to read you
that record it's it's there for your
asking
of course the president has refused to
provide that record precisely why did
ambassador Bolton direct Morrison to
tell the lawyers to talk to the lawyers
would you like a bastard Bolton to tell
you why he said that he'd be happy to
tell you why he said that he's therefore
you're asking what did vote know about
the freeze and aid prior to this meeting
in Warsaw what what did he mean that if
he can press Solinsky
who's gonna depend on whether compress
Solinsky she liked to know what that
meant I'd like to know what he meant by
that I think we know what he meant by
that Tim Morrison also conveyed the
substance of the song linear Mach pull
aside to his colleague ambassador Taylor
so this is now Tim Morrison told by
Bolton go talk to the lawyers and he
talks to also ambassador Taylor our
ambassador in Ukraine on the evening of
September 1st
I received a readout of the pencil insky
meeting over the phone from mr. Morrison
during which he told me but the
presidents of Linsky had opened the
meeting by immediately asking vice
president about the security cooperation
the vice president did not respond
substantively but said that he would
talk to President Trump that night the
Vice President did say that President
Trump one of the Europeans to do more to
support Ukraine and that he wanted the
Ukrainians to do more to fight
corruption during the same phone call
with mr. Morrison he described the
conversation ambassador Saarland had
with mr. Yermak in warsaw ambassador
sunland told mr. Yair Mach that the
Security Assistance money would not come
until President Solinsky committed to
pursue the verismo investigation I was
alarmed by what mr. Morrison told me
about the sunland year mock conversation
master teller then explained why he was
so alarmed by this turn let's hear that
as well you said previously that you
were alarmed to
this why were you alarmed it's one thing
to try to leverage a meeting in the
White House it's another thing I thought
to leverage security assistance security
assistance to a country at war dependent
on both the security assistance and the
demonstration of support it was it was
much more alarming the the White House
meeting was one thing security
assistance was much more alarming upon
learning from mr. Morrison that the
military aid may be conditioned on
Ukraine publicly announcing these two
investigations ambassador Taylor sends
an urgent text message to ambassador
Sandlin asking are we now saying that
security assistance and White House
meeting are conditioned on
investigations and the response by
ambassador Sandlin call me well you know
what that means right you get a text
message that's putting it in black and
white are we saying security assistance
in the White House meeting or condition
on investigations call me in other words
don't put this in writing call me
ambassador Taylor did in fact call
sunland informed by notes he took at the
time of the call he summarized that
conversation as follows during that
phone call ambassador Solomon told me
that President Trump had told him that
he wants president szalinski to state
publicly that Ukraine will investigate
Boris m'a and alleged Ukrainian
interference in the 2016 election
pastor Salman also told me that he now
recognized that he had made a mistake by
earlier telling Ukrainian officials that
only a White House meeting with
President Solinsky was dependent on a
public announcement of the
investigations in fact ambassador
Solomon said everything
dependent on such an announcement
including security assistance
he said that President Trump wanted
president Solinsky in a public box by
making a public statement about ordering
such investigations ambassador Taylor
testified that his contemporaneous notes
of the call reflect the song and used
the phrase public box to describe
president Trump's desire to ensure that
the initiation of his desired
investigations was announced publicly a
private commitment was not good enough
the State Department has ambassador
Taylor's extensive notes and of course
we would like to show them to you to
corroborate his testimony but pursuant
to the president's instructions the
State Department will not turn them over
you might recall from the tape yesterday
a bastard Taylor said they'll be shortly
coming I'm told
well somebody countermanded that
instructions who do we think that was
but you should see them if you have any
question about what Solomon told
ambassador Taylor if the president's
counsel tries to create any confusion
about what Solomon told Taylor about his
conversation with the president and
looks onlin they had one recollection in
his deposition in another recollection
in the first hearing and another
recollection in the declaration you want
to know exactly what happened in that
conversation when it was fresh in
Solomon's mind and he told Taylor about
it and Taylor wrote it in its notes
you're gonna want Taylor's notes in any
courtroom in America holding a fair
trial you would want to see
contemporaneous notes this Senate should
be no different to mend those notes
demand to see the truth we're not afraid
of those notes we haven't seen them we
haven't seen them maybe those notes say
something completely different maybe
those notes say no quid pro quo
maybe those notes say it's a perfect
call I'd like to see them I'm willing to
trust ambassadors Taylor's testimony and
his recollection
I'd like to see them I'd like to show
them to you they're yours for the asking
on September 25th the Washington Post
editorial board reported concerns that
President Trump was withholding military
assistance for you Ukraine and a White
House meeting in order to force
President Solinsky to announce
investigations of Vice President Biden
and purported Ukrainian interference in
the u.s. election the Post editorial
board wrote we're reliably told that the
president has a second and more venal
agenda he is attempting to force mr.
szalinski to intervene in the 2020
presidential election by launching an
investigation of the leading Democratic
candidate Joe Biden mr. Trump is not
just soliciting Ukraine's help with this
with his presidential campaign he is
using US military aid the country
desperately needs in an attempt to
extort it so that's September 25th
President on notice scheme discovered
September 5th September 7th the evidence
shows President Trump has a call with
Ambassador solid where the president
made the corrupt bargain for military
aid in the White House meeting even more
explicit on September 7th the master saw
and spoke to President Trump on the
telephone after that conversation
ambassador Solomon called Tim Morrison
to update him on that conversation
unlike Salman who testified that he
never took notes Morrison took notes of
the conversation and recalled it during
his public testimony let's listen now a
few days later on September 7th you
spoke again to Ambassador Sandlin who
told you that he had just gotten off the
phone with President Trump isn't that
right that sounds correct yes what did
ambassador Sandlin tell you that
President Trump said to him if I recall
this conversation correctly this was
where master Salman related that there
was no quid pro quo but President
szalinski had to make the statement and
that
had to want to do it and by that point
did you understand that the statement
related to the Biden into 2016
investigations I think I did yes and
that that was essentially a condition
for the security assistance to be
released
I understood that that's what ambassador
Saldana believed after speaking with
President Trump that's what he
represented now you should bear in mind
when mr. Morrison says that's what he
represented that we asked mr. Morrison
about the president's calls with
Ambassador Sunland and he testified that
every time he checked to see did
ambassador Stalin in fact talk with the
president when he said that he did that
yes in fact he talked with the president
every time he checked he was able to
confirm it now let's let this sink in
for a minute
according to mr. Morrison's testimony
former Republican staffer on the Armed
Services Committee
he speaks with Saarland on September 7th
and sahlan says he's just gotten off the
phone with Trump okay so this is
contemporaneous just got off the phone
call is fresh in everybody's mind and
what was said Morrison says ambassador
sauna related there was no quid pro quo
but President szalinski had to make this
statement and he had to want to do it no
quid pro quo but there's a quid pro quo
now
there are notes let me address some
super chats that are coming in good
questions all of them
Eileen Burke says any thoughts on
Trump's basic admission in Davos that he
was obstructing justice by them having
all the materials and the Democrats
don't have them ya already have been
researching that story for tomorrow's
show Eileen Trump said that everything's
going fine because he has all the
materials and the Democrats don't have
the materials which implies that they
are withholding evidence which is an
obstruction of Congress which is
something he's already been impeached
for the upside to that of course is I
guess he's already being impeached for
obstruction of Congress and therefore
you can't be impeached for that again I
don't know I'm just kind of thinking out
loud here fake Christians for Trump says
can I please get proof that Republicans
weren't there okay check my Twitter I'm
Deepak Minh on Twitter the reporter who
was in the room and McAuliffe I forget
what M stands for i retweeted his tweet
he said 21 Republicans are missing and
you know as I said earlier if you are
going to be deciding on Trump's guilt or
innocence don't you sort of have to be
there for this stuff
I guess not if your plan all along was
just to vote to acquit Donald Trump
which is of course indeed what
Republicans are planning to do so yeah
check out I tweeted it and you can the
reporter was in the room it's a primary
source I'm deep Hakman on Twitter which
by the way you should be following me on
Twitter got some pretty good takes about
apples on there if you check them out
keep the super chats coming I'll keep
popping in and answering them and let's
get back to Adam shifts narrative here
this is September 7 the conversation and
guess what ambassador Bolton said I
think you could probably figure this out
by now go talk to the lawyers go talk to
the lawyers and yet again for the third
time Morrison went to talk to the
lawyers about this conversation with a
master Salman
Morrison also called ambassador Taylor
to inform him about the conversation and
we have the testimony from bastard
Taylor about their conversation which is
also based on his contemporaneous notes
let's look at the conversation now
between mr. Morrison and ambassador
Taylor according to mr. Morrison
President Trump told ambassador Solomon
he was not asking for a quid pro quo but
President Trump did insist that
President Solinsky go to a microphone
and say he is opening investigations of
Biden and 2016 election interference and
that President Solinsky should want to
do this himself okay so here we have two
witnesses taking contemporaneous notes
both reflecting the same conversation
conversation between Solomon and the
president in which the president says no
quid pro quo but quid pro quo their
documents that prove this documents to
prove this that are yours for the asking
for people speculating in the chat that
Tulsi is missing from this hearing she's
a member of the house not the Senate so
she wouldn't she wouldn't be here she
has no part in it what's going on here
skee whom he spoke to after President
Trump guys multiple conversations with Z
meaning szalinski POTUS let's talk
salman spoke to taylor but not Volcker
shortly after this text ambassador
according to master Taylor who testified
again on his real time notes let's see
what that what he said the following day
on September 8th pastor Salman and I
spoke on the phone he confirmed that he
had talked to President Trump as I had
suggested a week earlier but that
President Trump was adamant that
President szalinski himself had to clear
things up and do it in public
president Trump said it was not a quid
pro quo
so it's all very consistent here what
the president said no quid pro quo but
szalinski must announce the
investigations publicly was what he was
telling Sunland no quid pro quo except
for the quid pro quo
the president's attorneys rely in the
first half of that sentence who would
like you to forget the second half ever
happened but we don't have to leave our
common sense at the door we don't have
to rely on an incomplete description of
that call we have instead the detailed
notes of mr. Morrison and ambassador
Taylor but we also know what President
Trump told Solomon because sunland
relayed that message to president
Solinsky during the same September 8th
conversation with Taylor sunlen
described his conversation with
President zolensky here's ambassador
Taylor's account of it Besser Soglin
also said that he had talked to
presidents of Linsky and mr Yermak and
had told them that although this was not
a quid pro quo if president Solinsky did
not clear things up in public we would
be at a stalemate I understood a
stalemate to mean that Ukraine would not
receive the much-needed military
assistance ambassador Sandlin said that
this conversation concluded with
president Solinsky agreeing to make a
public statement in an interview on CNN
so not only did he relate vaster song
and relate this conversation to mr.
Morrison and mr. Taylor not only to mr.
Taylor ambassador Taylor Mr Morrison
talked about it
but Solomon confirms that he's relayed
this conversation to Zielinski himself
everyone was now in the loop on the
military aid being withheld for the
political investigations good question
via super chat from frolf ganger who
says aren't senators required to be
present yes so for an impeachment
proceeding to be valid two-thirds of the
Senators need to be present in total but
the thing is the definition of president
seems to be at issue as long as you've
checked in for the day if you walk out
and it's not being monitored if it's not
controlled I think you still count as
present as far as that rule is concerned
and again it's up to the Chief Justice
John Roberts to actually enforce that so
good good luck with that and it's it's
just incredible it's incredible what it
is that's going on here
Ukrainians did not owe president Trump
anything a master tailor testified that
at the end of the Sandlin szalinski
conversation president Solinsky said
that he had relented and agreed to do a
CNN interview to announce the
investigations so there was a
breakthrough after all the promise
meeting wasn't enough the with held
security assistance broke the logjam
Solinsky was going to go on CNN and
announce the investigations Taylor
though remained concerned that even if
the Ukrainian leader did his president
Trump required president Trump might
continue to withhold the vital US
security assistance in any event bastard
Taylor texted his concerns to ambassador
Volcker and Sandlin stating the
nightmare is they give the interview and
don't get the security assistance the
Russians love it and I quit I mean
that's quite telling
- what's ambassador Taylor worried about
he's worried the Ukrainians are finally
good agree to do it they're gonna make
the announcement and they're still good
to get stiffed on the 8th at his
deposition ambassador Taylor elaborated
the nightmare scenario the nightmare is
the scenario where president Solinsky
goes out in public makes an announcement
that he's going to investigate burr yzma
and the interference in the 2016
election maybe among other things he
might put that in some series of
Investigations but the nightmare was he
would mention those to take all the heat
from that get himself in big trouble in
this country meaning Ukraine or this
country maybe the United States and
probably in this country as well meaning
both I guess
and this
security assistants would not be
released that was the nightmare if it
were happen tailors testified he would
quit early in the morning in Europe on
September 9th which was 1247 a.m. in
Washington DC ambassador Taylor
reiterated his concerns about the
president's quid pro quo for security
assistance in another series of text
messages with ambassadors Volcker and
Sunland so here are the September 9th
text messages tailor texts to Sandlin
the message to the Ukrainians
parenthesis and Russians we send with
the decision on security assistance is
key with a hold we have already shaken
their faith in us thus my nightmare
scenario and Taylor goes on and says
counting on you to be right about this
interview Gordon meaning if they do it
you darn well better come through with
the military aid and so on and says bill
I never said I was right I said we are
where we are and believe we have
identified the best pathway forward
let's hope it works
and Taylor said as I said on the phone I
think it's crazy to withhold security
assistance for help with a political
campaign bastard Taylor testified about
what he meant he said that to withhold
that assistance for no good reason other
than help with a political campaign made
no sense
it was counterproductive to all of what
we've been trying to do it was illogical
it could not be explained it was crazy
in response to ambassador Taylor's text
message song and replies at about 5:00
a.m. in Washington so the message from
Taylor goes out at 12:47 a.m. the
message back from song encompass at 5:00
a.m. so it looks like it may be five
hours later so Taylor has texted at
12:47 a.m. as I said on the phone I
think it's crazy withhold security
assistance for help with a political
campaign there he is again putting it in
writing for crying out loud
and Sandlin said
to call him about this stuff and so five
hours later you get this really
interesting message from Salman bill I
believe you're incorrect about present
Trump's intentions the president has
been crystal clear no quid pro quos of
any kind the president is trying to
evaluate whether Ukraine is truly going
to adopt to transparency and reforms
that President Solinsky promised during
his campaign I suggest we stop the
back-and-forth by text in other words
can you please stop putting this in
writing Congress may read this one day
if you still have concerns I recommend
you give Lisa canna or s a call to
discuss them directly Thanks now as you
can see ambassador Song and subsequent
testimony revealed that this text and
other denials of a quid pro quo were
intentionally false and simply designed
to provide a written record of a false
explanation that could later be used to
conceal wrongdoing the text message says
there were no quid pro quos of any kind
but you've seen his testimony he swore
under oath he was crystal clear when he
said there was a quid pro quo for the
White House meeting and he subsequently
testified there was a quid pro quo for
the security assistance as well as
confirmed by president Trump's direction
to him on September 7th song one's
recollection of his conversation with
President Trump as I mentioned has
evolved over time initially in his
deposition he testified that the
conversation with the president occurred
between Taylor's texts of September 9th
at 12:47 Washington time in his response
at 5:00 a.m. he recalled very little the
conversation at that time other than his
belief that his text message reflected
president Trump's response subsequently
though and again this is one of the
reasons why you do depositions in closed
session subsequently after the opening
statements of the testimony of
ambassador Taylor and mr. Morrison were
released which described an overlapping
and painful detail song ins conversation
with President Trump on September 7th
pastor Solomon submitted an addendum to
his deposition testimony which in
relevant part said this finally as of
this writing I cannot specifically
recall if I had one or two calls phone
calls with President Trump in the
September six to nine timeframe despite
recruited repeated requests to the White
House in the State Department I've not
been granted access to all the phone
records and I would like to review those
phone records along with any other notes
and other documents that may exist to
determine if I can provide a more
complete testimony to assist Congress
however although I have no specific
recollection of phone calls during this
period with mr. Taylor ambassador Taylor
Mr Morrison I have no reason to question
the substance of their recollection
about my September 1 conversation with
mr. Guerra macht during his public
testimony ambassador Solomon purported
to remember more of this conversation
with President Trump although he stood
still couldn't or maintained he couldn't
remember if it was on September 7th or
September 9th and according to his
testimony President Trump did not
specifically say there was a quid pro
quo but when Salman simply asked the
president what he wanted from Ukraine
president Trump immediately brought up a
quid pro quo
according to Saul and President Trump
said I want nothing I want no quid pro
quo I want Solinsky to do the right
thing and I said what does that mean and
he said I want him to do what he ran on
in a subsequent testimony master Salim
explained that president's Trump's
reference to what he ran on was a nod to
rooting out corruption here however
corruption like BER yzma has become code
for the investigations that President
Trump has sought so you've got
ambassador soglin's
emerging recollection
but what you've got is actually written
notes taken at the time that he does not
contest written notes of ambassador
Taylor and mr. Morrison notes which I
believe will reflect quite clearly the
understanding of dirt for dollars that
was confirmed by this telephone call
with President Trump well you weren't
dissuaded then right because you still
thought that the aid was conditioned on
the public announcement of the
investigations after speaking to
President Trump by September 8th that
was absolutely convinced it was and
President Trump did not dissuade you of
that in the conversation that you
acknowledged you had with him I don't
ever recall because that would have
changed my entire calculus a president
Trump had told me directly I'm not it's
not what I'm asking investor something
I'm just saying you still believed that
the security assistance was conditioned
on the investigation after you spoke to
President Trump
yes or no from a timeframe standpoint
yes okay so so here we have silence
saying that whatever his recollection
may be about that call he was still very
clear what the president wanted and he
was very clear there was a quid pro quo
that is consistent obviously with what
mr. Morrison has had to say and
ambassador Taylor in other words he
didn't believe president Trump's denial
of a quid pro quo and neither should you
Salman's understanding was further
confirmed by President Trump's own chief
of staff on October October 17 at a
press briefing in the White House Mick
Mulvaney admitted to president Trump
withheld the essential military aid for
Ukraine as leverage to pressure Ukraine
to investigate the conspiracy theory
that Ukraine had interfered in a 2016
election oh and that was those were the
driving factors that he also mentioned
to me and past the the the the the
corruption related to the DNC server
absolutely
no question about that but that's it
that's why we held up the money
when pressed that he had just convinced
that the very quid pro quo that
President Trump had been denying
Mulvaney doubled down let's listen to
that is a quid pro quo it is funding
will not flow unless the investigation
is it into the democratic server as well
we do we do that all the time with
foreign policy this evidence
demonstrates the president Trump
withheld the security assistance and the
White House meeting with President
Solinsky until Ukraine made a public
statement announcing the two
investigations targeted to help his
political reelection efforts but as you
will learn next he got caught and the
cover-up ensued
[Music]
mr. Chief Justice and senators thank you
for your patience this is a lot of
information but you have a very
important obligation and that is
ultimately to decide whether the
president committed impeachable offenses
and in order to make that judgment you
have to have all of the facts and so
we're going through this chronology
we're close to being done but it's
important to know that while all of this
material was going on these deals were
being made there were other forces at
work even before the president's freeze
on US military assistance to Ukraine
became public on August 28 members of
both houses of Congress began to express
concern on August 9th the Democratic
leadership of the House and Senate
Appropriations Committee and wrote to
the OMB in the White House warning that
a hold on assistance might constitute an
illegal impoundment of funds they urged
the Trump administration to follow the
law and obligate the funding when the
news of the frozen aid broke on August
28th congressional scrutiny of President
Trump's decision increased on September
3rd a group of senators both Republicans
and Democrats including senator jeanne
Shaheen Senator Rob Portman senator dick
durbin
Senator Ron Johnson Senator Richard
Blumenthal sent a letter to acting White
House chief of staff Mick Mulvaney
expressing and I quote deep concerns
that the administration is considering
not obligating the Ukraine Security
Initiative funds for 2020 19 two days
later as
has been mentioned on September 5th a
Washington Post editorial expressed
concern that president from whose walk
was withholding military assistance to
Ukraine in order to pressure president
Solinsky to announce these
investigations that was the first public
report linking the frozen security aide
to the investigations that mr. Giuliani
had been publicly pressing for and that
president prompt Trump as we've heard
had privately urged President szalinski
to conduct on the July 25th call that
same day senators Murphy and Johnson met
with President Solinsky and Kiev
ambassador Taylor went with them and he
testified mr. Taylor testified that
President solinsky's quote first
question to the Senators was about
withheld security assistance ambassador
Taylor testified that both senators
quote stressed that bipartisan support
for Ukraine and Washington was Ukraine's
the most important strategic asset and
that President Solinsky should not
jeopardize that bipartisan support by
getting drawn into u.s. domestic
politics now senator Johnson and Senator
Murphy later submitted letters where
they explained that they sought to
reassure President Solinsky that there
was bipartisan support in Congress for
providing Ukraine with military
assistance and that they would continue
to urge President Trump to lift the hold
here is what they said in that letter
senator Murphy said senator Johnson and
I assured Solinsky that Congress wanted
to continue this funding and would press
Trump to release it immediately and
Senator Johnson in the letter said I
explained that I tried to persuade the
president to authorize me to announce
the hold was released but that I was
unsuccessful now
as news of the president's hold on
military assistance to Ukraine became
public at the end of August Congress the
press the public started to pay more
attention to president Trump's
activities with Ukraine this risked
exposing the scheme that you've heard so
much about today by now the White House
had learned that the Inspector General
of the intelligence community had found
that a whistleblower complaint related
to the same Ukraine matter was quote
credible and quote an urgent concern and
was therefore that they were therefore
required to send that complaint to
Congress on September 9th three house
investigating committees sent a letter
to White House Counsel Pat supporti
stating that President Trump and
Giuliani quote appear to have acted
outside present outside legitimate law
enforcement and diplomatic channels to
coerce the Ukrainian government into
pursuing to politically motivated
investigations under the guise of
anti-corruption activity the letter also
said this if the president is trying to
pressure Ukraine into choosing between
defending itself from a Russian
aggression without US assistance or
leveraging its judicial system to serve
the ends of the Trump campaign this
would represent a staggering abuse of
power a boon to Moscow and a betrayal of
the public trust
the chairs requested that the White
House preserve all relevant records and
produce them by September 16th
this included the transcript or actually
the call record of the July 25th call
between President Trump and President
szalinski now based on witness testimony
it looks like the White House counsel's
office circulated the committee's
document requests around the White House
Tim Morrison
a senior director at the National
Security Council remembered seeing a
copy of this letter he also recalled
that the three committees Ukraine
investigation was discussed at a meeting
of senior level and a/c staff soon after
it was publicly announced Lieutenant
Colonel VIN Minh recalled discussions
among the NSC staff members that the
investigation and here's a quote might
have the effect of releasing the hold on
Ukraine military assistance because it
would be quote potentially politically
challenging for the administration to
justify that hold to Congress later that
same day on September 9th the Inspector
General informed the House and Senate
intelligence committees he determined
that the whistleblower complaint that
had been submitted on knocked on August
12th appeared to be credible met the
definition of urgent concern under the
statute and yet he reported that for the
first time ever the Acting Director of
National Intelligence was withholding
this whistleblower complaint from
Congress that violated the law which
required him dissented in seven days the
Acting Director later testified that his
office initially withheld the complaint
based on the advice from the White House
and an unprecedented intervention by the
Department of Justice now according to
public reporting and testimony from the
Acting DNI at a hearing before the House
Intelligence Committee on September 26th
the White House had been aware of the
whistleblower complaint for weeks prior
to the IG September 9th letter to the
intelligence committees Acting DNI
McGuire testified that when he received
the whistleblower complaint from the
Inspector General his office contacted
the White House counsel's office for
guidance consistent with Acting DNI
McGuire's testimony the New York Times
has reported that in late August the
president's current
fans council mr. Sibal oniy an NSC
lawyer John Eisenberg personally briefed
President Trump about the complaints
existence and told the president they
believe the complaint could be withheld
from Congress on executive privilege
grounds now on sceptered September 10th
the next day ambassador Bolton resigned
from his position as national security
adviser on that same day September 10th
chairmanship of the House Intelligence
Committee wrote a letter to the Acting
Director demanding that he provide the
complaint as the law required the next
day on September 11th president Trump
lifted the hold on the security
existence to Ukraine now numerous
witnesses have testified that they
weren't aware of any reason why the hold
was lifted just as there was no
explanation for the hole being
implemented there was no additional
review no additional European
contribution nothing to justify the
president's change in position except he
got caught just as there was no official
explanation for why the hold on
Ukrainian assistance was implemented
numerous witnesses testified that they
were not provided with any reason for
why the hold was lifted on September
11th for example Jennifer Williams who
was the special adviser to vice
president pence testified that she was
never given a reason for that decision
neither was lieutenant-colonel vin Minh
here's what he told us during the
hearing are you also aware however that
the security assistance hold was not
lifted for another ten days after this
meeting that's correct
and am I correct that you didn't learn
the reason why the hold was lifted
that's correct
Colonel VIN Minh you didn't learn a
reason why the hold was lifted either is
that right correct colonel women are you
aware that the committee's launched an
investigation into Ukraine matters on
September 9th two days
before the hold was lifted I am aware
and I was aware ambassador Taylor the
person in charge at the US Embassy in
Kiev who communicated the decision to
the Ukrainians also never got an
explanation here's what he said are you
also aware however that the Security
Assistance hold was not lifted for
another ten days after this knife
finally on September 11th I learned that
the hold had been lifted and security
systems would be provided I was not told
the reason why the whole had been
deferred Mark Zandi a career officer at
OMB testified he only learned of a
partial possible rationale for the hold
in early September after the Acting DNI
had informed the White House about the
whistleblower complaint now sandy
testified that sometime in early
September he received an email from his
boss Michael Duffy approximately two
months after the hold had been placed
the email quote attributed the hold to
the president's concern about other
countries not contributing more to
Ukraine and requested quote information
about what additional countries were
contributing to Ukraine this was a
different explanation then OMB had
provided at the July 26th interagency
meeting that referenced concerns about
corruption
Lieutenant Colonel testified that none
of the facts on the ground about
Ukrainian efforts to combat corruption
or other countries contribution to
Ukraine had changed before President
Trump lifted the hold according to a
press report after Congress began
investigating president Trump's scheme
the White House counsel's office opened
an internal investigation relating to
the July 25th call the following slides
provide excerpts from a report in The
Washington Post as part of that internal
investigation White House lawyers
reportedly
gathered and reviewed hundreds of
documents that reveal extensive efforts
to generate an after-the-fact
justification for the hold on military
assistance for Ukraine that had been
ordered by the president these documents
reportedly include quote early August
email exchanges between acting chief of
staff Mick Mulvaney and White House
budget officials seeking to provide an
explanation for withholding the funds
after the president had already ordered
a hold in mid-july on the nearly four
hundred million dollars in security
assistance the Washington Post article
also reported that in these this is a
quote emails show OMB director thought
and OMB staffers arguing that
withholding the aid was legal while
officials at the National Security
Council and State Department protested
OMB lawyers said that it was legal to
withhold the aid as long as they deemed
it a temporary hold you should be able
to see these documents but the White
House has withheld them from Congress so
the house can't verify the news report
but you could you you could do that if
you could see these documents you should
subpoena them and there is no reason not
to see all the relevant documents now
the lengthy delay created by president
Trump's hold prevented the Department of
Defense from spending all
congressionally appropriated funds by
the end of the fiscal year as we've
mentioned before that meant the funds
were going to expire on September 30th
because as we know unused funds do not
roll over to the next fiscal year this
confirmed the fears expressed by Cooper
sandy and others concerns that were
discussed within the relevant agencies
in late July and throughout August
approximately ultimately thirty five
million dollars of Ukraine military
assistance that's 14 percent of the DoD
funds remained on
Bente by the end of the fiscal year in
order to make sure that Ukraine did not
permanently lose the 35 million of
critical military assistance that had
been frozen by the White House Congress
had to pass a provision on September
27th three days before the funds were to
expire to ensure that the remaining 35
million could be sent to you cut Ukraine
now George Kent is an anti-corruption
and rule of law expert he told us that
American anti-corruption efforts
prioritized building institutional
capacity support for the rule of law not
the pursuit of individual investigations
particularly of political rivals here's
how explain the approach u.s. efforts to
counter corruption in Ukraine focus on
building institutional capacity so that
the Ukrainian government has the ability
to go after corruption and effectively
investigate prosecute and judge alleged
criminal activities using appropriate
institutional mechanisms that is to
create and follow the rule of law that
means that if there are criminal nexuses
for activity in the United States US law
enforcement should pursue the case if we
think there's been a criminal act
overseas that violates US law we have
the institutional mechanisms to address
that it could be through the Justice
Department and FBI agents assigned
overseas or through treaty mechanisms
such as the mutual legal assistance
treaty as a general principle I do not
believe the United States should ask
other countries to engage in selective
politically associated investigations or
prosecutions against opponents of those
in power because such selective actions
undermine the rule of law regardless of
the country now David Holmes concurred
during his testimony Holmes also
compared the official approach that we
believe in that we
promulgate across the world with what
the president and mr. Giuliani actually
we're doing so our long-standing policy
is to encourage them to establish and
build rule of law institutions that are
capable independence and that can
actually pursue credible allegations
that's our policy we've been doing that
for quite some time with some success so
focusing on particular cases including
particular cases where there is a
interest of the president's it's just
not part of what we've done it's hard to
explain why we would do that
unfortunately we do know the explanation
we know why President Trump wanted
president Zielinski to announce
investigations because it would help him
in his election now on September 18th
approximately a week before he was
supposed to meet with President Trump at
the United Nations General Assembly in
New York President szalinski spoke by
telephone with vice president pence
during her deposition Jennifer Williams
testify then she is the was vice
president Pence's assistant she had
testified that vice president pence
basically reiterated that the hold on
aid had been lifted and asked a bit more
about how zelinsky's efforts were going
and following her deposition and while
preparing for her testimony at the open
hearing on November 19th
Williams reviewed the documents they've
not been produced to us by the White
House and those documents refreshed her
recollection a vice president pence call
with president Zielinski now the White
House blocked Williams from testifying
about her refreshed recollections of the
vice president's call when she appeared
at the open public hearing they claimed
that certain portions of the September
8th 18th call including the information
that Williams wanted to tell us about
were classified on November 26th she
submitted a classified addition to her
hearing test
the mone where she provided additional
information about the vice-president's
September 18th telephone call with
president cywinski the intelligence
committee provided this classified
addition to the Judiciary Committee it
has been sent to the Senate for your
review now I've read that testimony I'll
just say that a cover-up is not a proper
reason to classify a document vice
president pence has repeatedly said
publicly that he has no objection to the
White House releasing the actual
transcript of his calls with President
Solinsky and yet his office has refused
many requests by the committee to
declassify Williams addendum so the
American people could also see the
additional evidence about this call we
urge the Senators to review it and we
ask again that the White House
declassify it as the house wrote in two
separate letters there is no basis to
keep it classified and again in case the
White House needs a reminder it's
improper to keep something classified
just to avoid embarrassment or to
conceal wrongdoing now we've been
through a lot of facts today we've seen
the president's scheme a shakedown of
Ukraine for his personal benefit was I
believe an obvious abuse of his power
but this misconduct the scheme became
exposed Congress asked questions the
Press reported non-political officers in
the government expressed concern the
whistleblower laws were activated as
this happened there was an effort to
create an after-the-fact
misleading record to avoid
responsibility for what the president
had actually been doing
these were not the only efforts to hide
misconduct and the misconduct continued
congressman Schiff will review some of
those items
so we have about 20 minutes left in the
presentation tonight I'd like to now go
through with you the president's efforts
to hide this corrupt scheme even as it
continued well into the fall of last
year on August 12th a whistleblower in
the intelligence community submitted a
complaint addressed to the congressional
intelligence committees this explosive
document stated that President Trump had
solicited foreign interference from
Ukraine to assist in his twenty20
re-election bid the complaint alleged a
scheme by President Trump to quote used
the power of his office to solicit
interference from a foreign country in
the twenty20 u.s. election the complaint
stated that the president had applied
pressure on Ukraine to investigate one
of the president's main domestic
political rivals and detailed the
involvement of the president's personal
lawyer Rudy Giuliani the complaint also
stated that the whistleblower believed
that the president's activities quote
pose risks to u.s. national security and
undermine the US government's efforts to
deter and counter foreign interference
in u.s. elections under the law the
whistleblower was required to file the
complaint with the Inspector General of
the intelligence community which was
then required to vet and assess the
complaint and determine if it warranted
reporting to the intelligence committees
the law gives the Inspector General 14
days to conduct an initial review and
then inform the Director of National
Intelligence about his findings on
August 26 the Inspector General sent the
whistleblower complaint and the
Inspector General's preliminary
determination to the Acting Director of
National Intelligence the Inspector
General wrote that based on a review his
review of the complaint its allegations
constituted an urgent concern and
appeared credible under the statute
inspector general confirmed that the
whistleblower acted lawfully in bringing
the complaint and credibly raised a
legitimate
concern that should be communicated to
the intelligence Committees of Congress
the Director of National Intelligence
quickly informed the White House about
the complaint under the law the Acting
Director of National Intelligence was
required to forward the complaint and
the Inspector General's determination to
the congressional intelligence
committees no later than 7 days after he
received it the legal requirement is
extremely clear upon receipt of the
transmittal from the IC IG that is the
Inspector General of the intelligence
community the director shall within
seven calendar days of such receipt
forward such transmittal to the
congressional intelligence committees
together with any comments the director
considers appropriate yet despite the
clear letter of the law the White House
mobilized to keep the information in the
whistleblower complaint from Congress
including by inviting the Department of
Justice to render an opinion as to
whether the complaint could be withheld
from Congress the statutory deadline of
September 2nd when the inspector when
the Director of National Intelligence
was required to turn her over to
Congress came and went and the complaint
remained hidden from Congress finally on
September 9th a full week after the
complaint was required to be sent to
Congress and once again an urgent
concern the Inspector General one week
after it was required to be sent to
Congress the Inspector General wrote to
the leaders of the intelligence
committees to inform them that the
Director of National Intelligence was
withholding a whistleblower complaint in
direct contravention of pact past
practice and the law on September 24th
the Speaker of the House Nancy Pelosi
announced that the House of
Representatives is moving forward with
an official impeachment inquiry the next
day the House of Representatives passed
a resolution calling on the Trump
administration to provide the
whistleblowers complaint immediately to
the congressional intelligence
committees later that day the White
House publicly released the summary of
the July
twenty-fifth call between President
Trump and president Solinsky and
permitted the Acting Director of
National Intelligence to provide the
whistleblowers complaint and related to
documents to the congressional
intelligence committees the President
himself was happy to discuss the
motivations for the scheme in public
that day in a joint press availability
with President Solinsky at the United
Nations General Assembly President Trump
reiterated that he wanted Ukraine to
investigate the Biden's but whatever he
can do in terms of corruption because
the corruption is massive
now when Biden's son walks away with
millions of dollars from Ukraine and he
knows nothing and they're paying a
millions of dollars that's corruption
when finally the day after President
Trump explained to the public that he
wanted Ukraine to investigate former
president vice president former Vice
President Biden on the morning of
September 26 the Intelligence Committee
publicly released Declassified
redactions of two documents the
whistleblowers August 12th complaint and
the Inspector General's August 26th
transmittal to the Acting Director of
National Intelligence even after the
impeachment inquiry into the Ukraine
matter began President Trump and his
proxy Rudy Giuliani have continued to
publicly urge President Solinsky to
launch an investigation of Vice
President Biden and alleged 2016
election interference by Ukraine on
September 30 during his remarks at the
swearing in of the new labor secretary
president Trump stated on the basis of
no corruption that's how we get elected
and I believe that he
but there was a lot of corruption having
to do with the 2016 election against us
and we want to get to the bottom of it
and it's very important that we do thank
you so here he is this meeting at the
United Nations September 30 and he's
still pursuing this bogus CrowdStrike
conspiracy theory with the president of
Ukraine on October 7 a second in a
public press availability president
Trump discussed the July 25th call with
president Solinsky and stated the
conversation was perfect it couldn't
have been nicer
he then linked his notion of corruption
with the Biden investigation on October
3rd and remarks before he departed a
marine one president Trump expressed his
hope that Ukraine would investigate Vice
President Biden and his son President
Trump actually escalated his rhetoric
urging not only Ukraine to investigate
the Biden's but China to
well I would think that if they were
honest about it that sort of major
investigation into the Bible it's a very
simple answer they should investigate
devises
because how does a company that's newly
formed and all these companies did you
look at and by the way
likewise China should start an
investigation into the binary because
what happened in China is just about as
bad as what happened with with Ukraine
so I would say that President Solinsky
if it were me I would recommend that
they start an investigation into the
Biden the same day president Trump
tweeted that he has an absolute right to
investigate corruption that really means
as he feels in it has an absolute right
to investigate or get foreign countries
to investigate his political opponents
the president sent a similar tweet the
next day once again linking corruption
with the Biden investigation as
president I have an obligation to end
corruption even if that means requesting
the help of a foreign country or
countries it is done all the time this
has nothing to do with politics or a
political campaign against the Biden's
this does have to do with corruption
I've give them credit for being so
obvious this has nothing to do with
politics or a political campaign against
the Biden's but you've got to
investigate the bites I guess that's
just a coincidence president Trump
continued to demonstrate his eagerness
to solicit foreign assistance related to
his personal interest here's what's okay
he said if we feel there's corruption
like I feel there was in the 2016
campaign there was tremendous corruption
against me if we feel this corruption we
have a right to go to a foreign country
president Trump added that asking
President Xi of China to investigate the
Biden's is certainly something we can
start thinking about even last month
even last month the President did
Giuliani's scheme continued during the
first week of December
Giuliani traveled to Budapest Kiev and
Vienna to meet with the former Ukrainian
govern officials as part of a continuing
effort to dig up dirt political dirt on
Vice President Biden and advanced the
theory that Ukraine interfered in the
2016 election asked about his interviews
of foreign Ukrainian prosecutors
Giuliani told the New York Times that he
was acting on behalf of his client
president Trump quote like a good lawyer
I am gathering evidence to defend my
client against the false charges being
leveled against him indeed evidence
obtained by the house from Giuliani's
associate confirms that he had been
representing himself in as early as May
twenty nineteen as president Trump's
personal lawyer doing Donald J Trump's
personal bidding in his dealings with
Ukraine this letter may 10th 2019 from
Giuliani - szalinski
says among other things however I have a
more specific request in my capacity as
personal counsel to President Trump and
with his knowledge and consent I request
a meeting with you on this upcoming
Monday May 13th or Tuesday May 14th I
will need no more than a half an
of your time and I will be accompanied
by my colleague Victoria tensing a
distinguished American attorney was very
familiar with this matter
police have your office let me know what
time or times are convenient for you and
Victoria and I will be there this is
evidence recently obtained showing his
effort to get that meeting in May with
szalinski Giuliani told The Wall Street
Journal that when he returned to New
York from this most recent trip on
December 7th President Trump called him
as his plane was still taxing down the
runway
what did you get he said President Trump
asked more than you can imagine
Giuliani replied Giuliani claimed that
he was putting his findings into a 20
page report that the president had asked
him to brief the Attorney General and
the Republicans in Congress shortly
thereafter on the same day President
Trump told reporters before departing on
marine one that he was aware of
Giuliani's efforts in Ukraine and the
Giuliani was going to report his
purported findings to the Attorney
General and Congress
[Music]
well I just know he came back from
someplace and he's gonna make a report I
think to the Attorney General and to
Congress he says he has a lot of good
information I have not spoken to him
about that information but Rudy as you
know has been one of the great crime
fighters of the last 50 years and he did
get back from Europe just recently and I
know he has not told me what he's found
but I think he wants to go before
Congress and say and also to the
Attorney General and the Department of
Justice
I hear he's found plenty yeah three days
after that those remarks on December
10th Giuliani confirmed to the
Washington Post a president Trump had
asked him to brief the Justice
Department and Republican senators on
his quote findings unquote from his trip
to Ukraine
Giuliani stated he wants me to do it I'm
working on pulling it together and hope
to have it done by the end of the week
that Friday December 13th Giuliani
reportedly met with President Trump at
the White House and on December 17th
Giuliani confirmed to CNN that President
Trump has been very supportive of his
efforts to dig up dirt on Vice President
Biden in Ukraine and that they are on
the same page the following day on
December 18 2019 the House of
Representatives approved the two
articles of impeachment you are
considering in this trial since the
house voted on these articles evidence
has continued to come to light related
to the president's corrupt scheme among
other things Freedom of Information Act
lawsuits press reporting and documents
provided to Congress from Rudy Giuliani
associate live for NAS further
corroborate what we already know about
the president's scheme as Giuliani again
said on December 17th President Trump
has been quote very supportive unquote
of his efforts to dig up dirt on Vice
President Biden and they are quote on
the same page
harness further corroborated what we
already know about president Trump's
scheme that he was responsible for
withholding the
military aid and sustaining that hold
and that his personal attorney mr.
Giuliani was working at the direction of
President Trump himself on December 20th
new emails were released showing that 91
minutes after President Trump's call
with ukrainian President Solinsky a top
Office of Management budget aide asked
the Department of Defense to withhold to
hold off on sending military aid to
Ukraine so those were new documents that
came on December 20th on December 29th
revelations emerged from OMB director
and acting chief of staff McMullen E's
roll about them about that role in the
delay of aid and efforts by lawyers at
OMB the Department of Justice and the
White House to justify the delay and the
alarm that the delay caused within the
administration those records just became
available on December 29th On January
2nd newly unredacted pentagon emails
which raised serious concerns by Trump
administration officials about the
legality of the president's hold on aid
became available
On January 6th former Trump national
security adviser John Bolton announced
that he would comply with a Senate
subpoena compelling his testimony
his lawyers stated that he has new
relevant information On January 13th
reports emerged that the Russian
government hacked the Ukrainian gas
company BIR yzma almost certainly in an
effort to find information about Vice
President Joe Biden's son in order to
weaponize that information against mr.
Biden and in favor of mr. Trump just as
Russia did against Secretary Clinton in
favor of then-candidate Trump in 2016
that brings us up to January 13th of
this year
last week House committees received new
evidence from lab partners that further
demonstrates that the president was a
central player in this scheme to
pressure Ukraine for his political gain
and also last week the Government
Accountability Office found the
president Trump violated the law when he
withheld that aid
last night we had a further development
when more redacted emails from the
Office of Management and Budget were
produced I think representative Crowe
showed you these these are among the
documents that were just released I'm
sure that if we could read under those
redactions it would be a very perfect
email but you have to ask what is being
redacted here
what is so important to keep
confidential during the course of an
impeachment inquiry as you can see right
up until last night evidence continues
to be produced the truth is going to
come out indeed the truth has already
come out but more and more of it will
more emails are going to come out more
witnesses are going to come forward
they're gonna have more relevant
information to share and the only
question is do you want to hear it now
you want to know the full truth now do
you want to know just who was in the
loop sounds like everyone was in the
loop you want to know how broad this
scheme was we have the evidence to prove
the president Trump ordered the aid
withheld he did so to course Ukraine to
help his reelection campaign he withheld
a White House meeting to coerce the same
sham investigations we can and will
prove president Trump guilty of this
conduct and of obstructing the
investigation into his misconduct but
you and the American people should know
who else was involved in this scheme
you should want the whole truth to come
out
you should want to know about every
player in this sorted business
it isn't within your power to do so and
I would urge you even if you are
prepared to vote to convict and impeach
and remove this president to find out
the full truth about how far this
corruption goes because I think the
public has a right to know now
today well yesterday we made the case
for why you should hear this additional
evidence and testimony this morning I
introduced you to the broad sweep of the
president's conduct and then during the
course of today we walk you through a
factual chronology in real time about
how this plot unfolded and during that
factual chronology today you saw that in
March of this year Giuliani began that
smear campaign against ambassador
Jovanovic in order to get her fired by
President Trump something he would later
admit was necessary to get her out of
the way because she was going to be in
the way of these two investigations this
is the supposed anti-corruption effort
by the President to get rid of a woman
who has dedicated her career to
representing the United States often in
dangerous parts of the world to fighting
corruption and to promoting the rule of
law this plot begins with getting her
out of the way with the president saying
that she's going to go through some
things
this anti-corruption reformer this u.s.
Patriot this plot begins with getting
her out of the way and telling Lee and
this says so much about the
administration tellingly it wasn't
enough
just to recall her or fire her the
had done that done at any time no they
wanted to destroy her because she had
the audacity to stand in their way so we
heard in March about the effort to get
rid of her and it succeeded and guess
what message that sent to the Ukrainian
if Adam Schiff could cry in the wrap-up
face here I think it would be great
where has the Ukrainians were watching
this whole saga they were hearing his
interviews they were seeing the smears
that he was putting out and this
attorney for the president working hand
in hand with these corrupt Ukrainians
was able to get a um bastard yanked out
of her job proof-positive you want a
window to this president you want entree
to this president you want to make
things happen with this president you go
through his lawyer
never mind the State Department never
mind the national security of counsel
never mind the Defense Department you go
through his lawyer that's March April
zalinsky has this huge victory in the
presidential election he gets a
congratulatory call from the president
the president assigns Mike vice
president pence to go to the
inauguration may Giuliani is rebuffed by
Solinsky cancels the trip to Ukraine
the one where he wanted to go remember
metal in the investigation because
Giuliani says enemies of trumps around
szalinski guess that means he didn't get
the meeting and they must be enemies of
the president of course the Ukrainians
know why he wants that meeting may Trump
disinvite Spence to the inauguration
fences going Giuliani's rebuffed pence
ain't going that's me instead may 23rd
we have this meeting at the White House
and there's a new a new party in town
the three amigos
they're gonna be handling the Ukraine
portfolio and they're told worked with
Rudy
work with Rudy pastor Sandlin ambassador
Volker secretary Perry work with me and
as you saw on June Giuliani's pushing
for these investigations and the trying
to arrange these meetings and trying to
make this happen and also in June the
Defense Department announces they're
gonna release the military aid the
president reads about this and then he
stops it he stops the aid in July on
July 10th you heard in the chronology
there's that meeting at the White House
the meeting in which Sandlin blurts out
in this meeting between Ukrainians and
Americans hey they've got a deal they're
trying to get this meeting and there's a
debate about what the meet is gonna
happen and when it's gonna happen and
Solomon says hey we've got a deal with
Mulvaney here we're gonna get this
meeting and you're gonna do those
investigations and Bolton stiffens and
abruptly ends the meeting that was the
first meeting that day and then Salman
brings the delegation to a different
part of the White House and they had the
follow-up meeting where he makes it even
more explicit this drug deals made even
more explicit and dr. hill is told by
ambassador Bolton you need to go talk to
the lawyers I don't want any part of
this drug deal they're cooking up that's
July July is the month where that email
goes from solid to Pompeo and others and
everybody is in the loop July is the
month where the hold is implemented with
no explanation July is the month where
Muller testifies about Russia's systemic
interference in our affairs July is the
month after Muller testifies that the
President believes he has escaped
accountability the next day in July is
of course the July 25th call
in which the president asks for his
favor and July is the month July 26 is
the date of the call between President
Trump and ambassador Sunland you know
the one zalinsky loves your ass he'll do
anything you want is he gonna do the
investigation yeah he's gonna do the
investigation July is the month of that
conversation between Sunland and David
Holmes where Holmes says can you can you
tell me candidly here what the president
thinks of Ukraine does he give a blank
about Ukraine no he doesn't give a blank
about Ukrainian lis cares about the big
stuff well there's kind of big stuff
here in Ukraine like a war with the
Russians no no no big stuff that affects
him personally like the Biden
investigation that Giuliani wants that's
the month of July August we have that
meeting between Giuliani and the air
Mach in Madrid August we have the
back-and-forth of about the statement no
you go first and you commit and publicly
announced investigations and then we'll
give you date no you go first you give
us the date and then we'll announce the
investigations well we'll give you a
statement that doesn't mention the
specifics no no you give us a statement
that mentions in this investigations
that's the month of August August is
also the month where it becomes clear
that it's not just the meeting anymore
it's everything everything is
conditioned on these investigations the
relationship the money the meeting
[Music]
sunlen and Holmes testify it's as simple
as two plus two equals four that's
August September Sandlin says the Gare
mock everything is conditioned on public
announcement so message delivered no
ambiguity the Ukrainians are told quid
pro quo
tailor texts this is crazy to withhold
aid
September's the month September seventh
the particular Trump and Sunland talked
on the phone and the president has the
conversation where he says no quid pro
quo except here's the quid pro quo
solinsky's gotta go to the mic and
what's more he should want to do it
September is also the month where the
investigations begin in Congress
September's the month where after those
investigations begin after the president
knows he's been caught the aide is
finally released and September is the
month where Pence and szalinski are on
the phone and Jennifer Williams has
classified information to share with you
that I hope you will take a look at
because it is relevant to these issues
that's September October Trump admits
yes if it wasn't obvious enough he wants
Ukraine to investigate his political
opponent October is the month where he
invites another nation China to
investigate his opponent this is the
broad outline of the chronology that we
went through today tomorrow we will go
through the law the Constitution and the
facts as they apply to article one yea
Republicans don't care about that
tomorrow we've introduced the case we've
gone through the chronology and tomorrow
we will apply the facts to the law as it
pertains to the president's abuse of
power
and let me just conclude this evening by
remarking again on what brought us here
what brought us here is that some
courageous people came forward
courageous people that risk their entire
careers and one of the things that's
been so striking to me about that as I
watch these witnesses like Maria
Jovanovic and ambassador Taylor and
David Holmes and others dr. hill is how
much these dedicated officials were
willing to risk their career the
beginning of their career or the middle
of the career or late in their career
when they had everything to lose but
people senior to them who have every
advantage who sit in positions of power
lacked that same basic commitment lacked
that same basic willingness to put their
country first and expose wrongdoing why
is it that Colonel VIN Minh who worked
for fiona hill who worked for john
bolton and dr. Kupperman why is it that
they were willing to stick their neck
out and answer lawful subpoenas when
their bosses wouldn't I don't know that
I can answer that question but I just
can tell you I have such admiration for
the fact they did
I think and and and and I think this is
some form of cosmic justice that this
ambassador that was so ruthlessly
smeared is now a hero for her courage
there is justice in that but what will
really vindicate that leap of faith that
she took is if we show the same courage
they risked everything their careers and
yes I know what you're asked to decide
may risk yours too but if they could
show the courage
so can we I yield back
wow wow what a day what a day
presumably some kind of wrap-up and plan
to resume tomorrow of the 100th Congress
a single one-page classified document
identified by the house managers for
filing with the Secretary of the Senate
that will be received on January 22nd
2020 shall not be made part of the
public record and shall not be printed
but shall be made available pursuant to
the standing order from the 100th
Congress the majority leader is
recognized mr. Chief Justice colleagues
were almost through for the evening will
convene again at one o'clock tomorrow
before we adjourn I'd like to
acknowledge that tomorrow is the
official last day for this term Senate
pages this group
[Applause]
we're going to get through your comments
do a secret shot right after this so
feel free to send those in I'll hang as
long as they're questions and comments
via super chat that in addition to
witnessing this unusual event that we're
all experiencing they're there studying
for their final exams as well and we
wish them well as they head off back to
boring normal high school mr. leader
let me just add my thanks and gratitude
for all of us it is rare particularly
these days when a hundred senators from
both sides of the aisle of every
political persuasion get up and give
someone a standing ovation but you
deserve it thank you for your good work
and we hope you have beautiful and
successful lives thank you so mr. Chief
Justice I ask unanimous consent that on
Tuesday January the 28th from 10:00 a.m.
to 11:00 a.m. while the Senate is
sitting as a court of impeachment and
that notwithstanding the Senate's
adjournment hmm the Senate can receive
house messages and executive matters
committees be authorized to report
legislation and executive matters and
senators be allowed to submit statements
for the record bills resolutions and
co-sponsors requests and were applicable
the Secretary of the Senate on behalf of
the printing of the presiding officer be
permitted to refer such matters without
objection so ordered finally I ask
unanimous consent the trial adjourn
until 1:00 p.m. Thursday January 23rd
and this also constitute the adjournment
of the Senate out objection so ordered
Senate is a jerk an incredible day truly
an incredible day Adam Schiff laying out
the case a big picture against Donald
Trump and tomorrow they will continue
with the second day hours 9 through 16
we will stay right here I have a bunch
of super chats I see people getting very
very worked up that
may have missed theirs I'm gonna go
right back to where we left off during
the last break we will do super chats
for a little while I will do new member
announcements maybe we could get to 123
I am just saying you know we're here
let's let's do it we're only 20 away 103
would be a weird number to end on so I
invite you to take advantage of the
impeach we are celebrating impeachment
with a coupon code impeach 50 that saves
you 50% okay let's get right to what is
on people's minds azeema
Abu Khalil says our Senate Republicans
starting to turn on McConnell I did not
see evidence of that I have not seen
evidence of that so far quirky quips
says can Justice Roberts say anything
about missing senators or strike them or
find them he could there's been no real
indication that Justice Roberts is
actually going to hold Republicans
accountable to the rules as I mentioned
earlier it was reported that and maybe I
can even pull up the tweet well let's
let's stay on this for now it was
reported earlier by a reporter in the
room that when Adam Schiff was giving
his earlier remarks 21 of the 53
Republicans were just gone they were
they were just gone and of course I
tweeted at D Pakman jokingly how will
they know whether to acquit or convict
if they don't see the testimony the the
arguments of course we know it doesn't
matter they've already made the decision
on that Punisher 38 says it's up to the
CJ himself to enforce attendance that's
right it is up to John Roberts he's not
going to do it though Jay Harper says if
Schiff cried wouldn't it feed into the
beta male narrative that trumpets love
to accuse liberals of being probably I
wasn't seriously saying shift should try
but he does speak very eloquently and
emotionally but not in a negative way
just with emotion John McKinney says why
isn't Catcher in the Rye on your book
recommendations it's my favorite book of
all time I you know not every book is on
my list of book recommendations at david
pakman.com slash recommendations many
books are I have I didn't it's really
books I've read an adulthood I haven't
read that since middle school or
whenever you read it so that's why it is
not there
thanks to also-ran for becoming a soy
boy by signing up for a youtube
subscription Jay Harper Seven says ship
is
an eloquent speaker future senator or
president Adam Schiff seems to have a
big career in front of him he might only
be flick in his late 40s shift 49 or 50
or something like that he could have a
long time ahead of him for sure
Sabrina Zafar checking in with the
message love you David hey Sabrina good
to see you I've met Sabrina in person
and Sabrina's here in Boston great to
see you glad you've glad you've been
here or I guess I don't know if you have
you you sent the super shot a few
minutes ago I know you've been here four
minutes anyway James Montalbano says
have you referred have you ever referred
to him as president Trump in your
private life in earnest of course not no
I just say Trump I realized today that I
never have and never will okay all right
thank you James
very very interesting okay any other
questions or comments that people have
I'll stay if the questions continue to
come in super chat is the dollar sign at
the bottom of the chat if you're on a
desktop computer and it is sort of an
overlay dollar sign if you are on mobile
if you don't know if you're on a desktop
computer or on mobile you're probably
not going to be I'm not expecting you to
send a super chat let me put it that way
if you are if you're unaware of whether
you are on a computer or on a mobile
phone
Madeline Welsh not pleased with the
comment about Catcher in the Rye
Madeline Welsh says Catcher in the Rye
isn't that good
you know Madeline that there's a lot of
people who actually feel that way a lot
of people have told me a lot of people
don't know this that there are lots of
people that feel very strongly against
Catcher in the Rye and they quite
frankly don't really care too much about
Holden Caulfield Caulfield hope I'm
pronouncing the last name correctly but
anyway we don't have to like argue about
Catcher in the Rye we have much bigger
things let's go to I want to check
Donald Trump's Twitter account to see if
he's been tweeting any other nonsense
recently six no it's just a bunch of
retweets continuing to retweet nonsense
Doug Collins nonsense and so on and so
forth let me see if I can find let me
see that tweet that I mentioned earlier
oh here it is let's see where was that
tweet here it is here's the tweet from
michael mcauliffe just counted 21 empty
seats on the Republican side of the
Senate - on the Democratic side a couple
hours in two shifts presentation some
are just stretching their legs but most
are not in the chamber some of them have
been out there for a while yeah that
that's not that's not the way it's
supposed to go you're supposed to be
there for the testimony
Ryan Henry Dean weighing in via super
chat says catcher and the rise actually
incredible okay so you know it's a book
people can have different opinions about
it we know Donald Trump obstruct Oh
Angus king with a banana coming in out
of nowhere with a banana and it's a hand
banana love angus King getting potassium
and all sorts of nutriments as one of my
teachers used to say people can disagree
about Catcher in the Rye it's harder to
disagree about you know Trump Trump
obstructed justice but we can certainly
all respectfully disagree about Catcher
in the Rye I see a few messages from
people saying that the coupon code is
not working the coupon code is
absolutely working let me walk you
through it
join pakman.com join pakman.com join
pakman.com works on monthly works on
yearly you click sign up coupon code
field impeach 50 as soon as you tab off
of this field the price drops by 50%
working beautiful thing beautiful
beautiful thing this is a busy time of
day for the website people getting
today's podcast and whatnot so that may
slow things down so today Democrats had
eight hours house managers I should call
them house managers had eight hours they
used seven hours and 15 minutes meaning
they still have you know a whole bunch
of hours remaining certainly more than
enough for two very very full day's
upcoming captain crunch says David in
Hillier in 2016 Hilary destroyed Bernie
and cow
fornia California tends to be not as
progressive as Massachusetts in my
opinion what are the chances California
goes Biden is California a must-win for
Bernie
neither let me explain this to you fine
folks let me see if I can pull up the
polling data we'll look at California so
right now in California there's
conflicting polls let me zoom this in
there we go
so one poll says Biden 30 Bernie 20
another poll says Biden 24 Bernie 27
another poll says Biden 19
Bernie 26 here's the thing about
California it is proportional
apportionment I hope is that the does
that make sense proportional
apportionment it is pro rata
apportionment of Delegates so if Bert if
Bernie gets 20% of the vote and Biden
gets 30 they roughly get 20 and 30% of
the delegates respectively if Biden is
24 27 whatever right it's proportional
apportionment so it is it is unlikely to
be make-or-break for anybody okay looks
like things of god are we still oh they
are still life so no it's it's not it's
it's an unlikely state to make or break
it for for anybody
zees private youtube says bananas are
enslaved potassium hashtag free
potassium that's a movement I think we
can all get behind Jay Harper says what
keeps you happy or positive in life I've
been down down lately I recommend taking
a break from politics over the weekend
that that is something I recommend to
everybody all sorts of things happening
here and it looks like it looks like
they have indeed wrapped for the day so
what I recommend is have planned breaks
from politics
I want to welcome Brandon Jett as the
newest David Pakman show member Brandon
is new member number 104 of the
impeachment streams our goal is a
hundred and twenty three new members
just for there's no reason nothing
special about 123 it's just you know
it's the goal the number is 123 we are
at 104 and I really appreciate
every every one of the hundred and four
okay on that note I think that that is
probably enough for today we will pick
it back up tomorrow Oh somebody's
keeping me here with a super chat how
annoying would that be if every time I'm
ready to wrap someone sends a super chat
ex is asking [ __ ] calling to c-span
tonight or otherwise i c-span may be
done
I'm not let me see what is going on
c-span live let me pull up a different
feed c-span may be done but I'd consider
trying to call in to c-span let's see
what is going on on c-span it'll just
take me a moment here I've got to figure
out what my credentials are let's see
here nope those were not the right ones
that's too bad
try another set of credentials oh man
that's not it either
all right I'm gonna try one more set of
credentials and then if not that might
have to be it ah there we go I got okay
c-span live I guess it is c-span - that
is the one we should be taking a look at
let's see what happened your unfiltered
view of government created by cable in
1979 everything businesses or not so
that's probably it you know a day oh
look my prediction is the president nine
states will be acquitted of the all
right if they start taking calls then
maybe I will go ahead and try to call in
the daughter of slaughter says David
you're looking fresh and clean
especially near button-ups anyway you
could teach Sam seed our how to iron a
dress shirt I'd be glad to I was
actually someone called in to my show
earlier and referred to Sam as Sam cider
which is hilarious because he is all
into apples which is an interesting
thing to be into I find apples
interesting and I was texting with him
earlier we commiserated about YouTube
just you know we commiserated about
YouTube I would love to teach Sam to
iron anytime he wants I will teach him
Daniel DARAB says I love what you do
David at
add me on Li Ches Danny J one I'll hit
you with a correspondence game tonight
okay we'll see about that yeah I get so
many requests I'm David Pakman on Ches
calm and I'm Pakman David Onley Ches and
I get so many requests that I tend to
just ignore them quite frankly because
it just gets it gets a little bit hectic
and it gets it gets hard to to keep up
with all the games and then people get
mad and you know it just gets very very
crazy alright that does it for me today
we'll pick it back up tomorrow thanks